ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL FOR AGES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD THE
RHIZOME GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG HELLO
HUESO TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE SIX YEARS MITCHELL
MONNING. MORE LOCK MORALE
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER EARN- BERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WELL. THANK
YOU MA'AM. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT MEMBERS WOULD YOU AND
OUR GUEST BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
WE'LL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BUYER CHAPLAIN SISTER
MACHEL GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR PAN. LET
US REMEMBER THIS WE'RE ALWAYS
IN GOD'S PESENCE. A CATHARINE
MACAULAY A SAID TO THE SISTERS
OF MERCY ONE TIME THIS IS OUR
LIFE JOYS AND SORROWS MINGLES
ONE SUCCEEDING THE OTHER. THIS
PAST WEEKEND IN MANY PARTS OF
THE WORLD PEOPLE CELEBRATED NEW
LUNAR NEW YEAR AND THE YEAR OF
THE RAT. WITH CELEBRATION COMES
JOINING. ENJOY A IS A SIGN OF
ENLIGHTENMENT. THE BUDDHIST
MONKS TAKE NOT HAN SAYS
ENLIGHTENMENT IS ALWAYS THERE.
SMALL AND LIKE HUMANS WILL
BRING GRACE AND LIKE MEN'S. IF
YOU BREATHE IN AND ARE AWARE
THAT YOU WERE ALIVE. THOSE YOU
CAN TOUCH THE MIRACLE OF BEING
ALIVE THEN BASS IS A KIND OF
ENLIGHTENMENT. AND TODAY WE
ALSO PRAY TO OUR GOD OF SORROWS
ON THIS DAY OF PAINFUL MEMORIES
MARKING SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
SINCE THE LIBERATION OF THE
JEWISH SURVIVORS AT ODDS WITH.
AND SO WE PRAY MAY WE BE
ENLIGHTENED ENOUGH TO VALUE ALL
PERSONS FOR THEIR PRESENCE
THERE GIVE. THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE ONGOING EVOLUTION OF OUR
CIVILIZATION'S. MAY WE BANISH
FROM OUR HEARTS FEAR PREJUDICE
ARROGANCE AND ALL THOSE WOULD
PREVENT US FROM APPRECIATING
THE BEAUTY OF OUR LIVES AND THE
JOY WE CAN SHARE IN TRULY
ENCOUNTERING ONE ANOTHER. AND
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND SALUTING OUR
pALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF
AMERICA AND. AND THE FULL WOULD
PROVISIONS ARE. YOU TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO START WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SENATOR ATKINS TO HAVE A
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR PERCY
AND YOU'RE READY I DO MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I'M GONNA ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY WILL TAKE
THEIR SEATS. I HAVE A VERY
SPECIAL PRESENTATION AND I KNOW
THAT EVERYONE WILL BE MOST
INTERESTED IN THIS ONE. SO LET
ME ASK OUR- SERGEANT JODY
BARNES TO SERVE OUR NET TO STEP
UP. IT IS CERTAINLY WITH THE
MOTION AND MIXED FEELINGS. TO
ADDRESS THE IMPENDING
RETIREMENT OF OUR CHIEF
SERGEANT JODY BURNETT. IN FACT
I WOULD OFFICIALLY PROTEST HIS
LEAVING BUT I FIGURE PROTESTS
OR ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE'S
GOING TO MISS LEAST ABOUT THE
CAPITAL SO I MUST LET IT GO. IN
HIS SERVICE TO THE SENATE JODY
HAS BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SAFETY AND THE SECURITY OF MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED SENATORS. OUR
STAFFS AND THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF VISITORS. AND HE
HAS ALWAYS CARRIED OUT HIS
DUTIES WITH A QUIET STRENGTH A
PROFESSIONALISM AND WITH GOOD
HUMOR. NOW JODY BEING JODY HE
ASKED IF THERE WAS A
RECOGNITION LIKE THIS TO OCCUR.
THAT FOCUS ON HIS PARTNERS AS
WELL. AND SO I WILL ACCOMMODATE
YOU IN THAT REQUEST MISTER
BARNETT. THAT INCLUDES THE
OUTSTANDING TEAM OF SENATE
SERGEANTS OF COURSE WHO WE TURN
TO EVERY DAY AND FOR WHOM JODY
HAS HAD THE GREATEST RESPECT
AND AFFECTION. INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL WHO
JODY WANTED TO EMPHASIZE HAS
BEEN SUCH A STRONG PARTNER BOTH
HERE. AND IN THE CAPITAL IN
ENSURING SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
OUR DISTRICT OFFICES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I WAS MOMENTARILY
HARD WHEN I RECALL THE JODIE'S
FULL NAME IS JUDY BARNETT THE
THIRD NOW I THOUGHT THAT MIGHT
MEAN THERE WAS A WHOLE STRING
OF JODIE BARNETT'S AND WE CAN
JUST POP A NEW WHEN INDUSTRY
SERGEANT ONE RIGHT AFTER
ANOTHER. APPARENTLY THAT'S NOT
THE CASE AND THAT'S NOT HOW IT
WORKS SO WE'LL JUST HAVE TO
LOOK ELSEWHERE TO FEEL THOSE
INCREDIBLY NICE BIG SHOES. IS
JOINED TODAY BY COUSIN KELLY
DARDEN AND CUT LEAD IS HERE
SOMEWHERE- WE'RE LOOKING FOR
YOU TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT JODY
TAKES FULL ADVANTAGE OF HIS
RETIREMENT IF HE INTENDS TO
LEAVE US AND I. HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK WITH YOU AND I KNOW THAT
YOU TAKE THAT- THAT SERIOUSLY-
PERSONALLY I JUST HAVE TO SAY
WHEN I STEP. IN AND HE WAS ALSO.
TO RETIRE- AND THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY GRACIOUS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT I NEEDED-
STABILITY STRENGTH
PROFESSIONALISM AND SOMEONE
THAT I CAN LEAN ON AND TRUSTS
AND THAT HAS BEEN. JODY
BARNETT. SO WE WANT TO THANK
YOU WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE YOU
AND I ALSO SEE THAT ARE
REPUBLICAN LEADER- MADAM
PRESIDENT I WILL TURN IT BACK
TO YOU SO THAT YOU CAN
RECOGNIZE OTHERS. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM. SENATOR PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. YOU KNOW JODIE
AT I KNOW ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES
FEEL THE SAME WAY THAT OF.
LIFETIMES OF DEDICATION N.
PROTECTION EXPERIENCE ALL THOSE
THINGS LIKE WITH DOTSON IN YOU
SERVING IN THIS BUILDING AND-
THAT'S A HUGE GAP TO FEEL. OF
ALL OF YOUR EXPERIENCE IN A
LIFETIME OF DEDICATION THAT
YOU'VE GIVEN ALL OF US. I WANT
TO THANK YOU- VERY MUCH FOR THE
SERVICE THAT YOU PROVIDED NOT
ONLY TO ALL FORTY OF US IN
SAFETY AND SECURITY BUT ALSO TO
YOUR STAFF. AND HOW KIND AND
GENTLE YOU ARE I ALSO WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT. SERIOUSLY I
THINK MY CANDY JARS GOING TO BE
A LITTLE BIT. HIGHER LEVELS
WITHOUT YOU FREQUENT FLYING MY
CANDY JAR AND ALL THE TIME BUT
YOU ARE WELCOME ANYTIME TO COME
BY AND PICK UP YOUR FAMOUS
WORST USE THAT ARE ONLY
PRODUCED IN MY DISTRICT BECAUSE
I KNOW THOSE ARE YOUR FAVES.
AND I APPRECIATE THE FRIENDSHIP
THAT HAD AS YOU COME IN MY
OFFICE TO AND- TO FREQUENT FLY
MY CANDY BAR. I GUESS YOU WOULD
SAY. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON A SERIOUS NOTE
FOR ALL THE WORK IN THE
DEDICATION THAT YOU FIT
TOGETHER. TO KEEP AGAIN ALL OF
US SAFE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
GOES ON IN THIS BUILDING- WITH
PEOPLE PROTESTING. AND MAKING
SURE THAT YOUR STAFF A SECURE
AND SAFE TO AND YOU HAVE A-
VERY PROFESSIONAL OUTSTANDING
STAFF. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED. SO I AGREE WITH THE
SENATE PRO TEM. BE GREATLY
TWEET YOU THE VERY BEST IN YOUR
RETIREMENT- AND WE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE
DONE FOR ALL OF US. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROUP PORTANTINO.
OBVIOUSLY I WANT TO ADD MY
APPRECIATION THEN- WELL WISHES
TO JODIE BUT I ALSO WANT TO
SHARE A LITTLE PERSONAL STORY
THAT I ACTUALLY MET HIS MOM.
BEFORE I MET JODI SO WHEN I WAS
CAMPAIGNING FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY HIS MOM STARTED
TALKING TO ME ABOUT HER SON AND
THIS GUY NAMED JOE DO YOU I'M
GONNA GET TO SEE AND SERVE WITH
AND- YOU KNOW SHE WAS RIGHT YOU
ARE EVERYTHING SHE SAID SHE
WASN'T JUST A MOM BRAGGING
ABOUT HER SON SHE WAS A MOM
TELLING THE TRUTH. AND SHE
WELCOMED ME INTO HER CHURCH
CONGREGATION AND YOU WELCOME ME
HERE AND ONE DAY OUT AND I
THINK IT WAS A CHRISTMAS
WEEKEND MEANT THAT CHURCH AGAIN
AND I LOOK OVER THERE'S JODY
SIT IN CHURCH WITH HIS MOM AND
SO YOU KNOW WE SAY- GREAT MOM
GREAT SON AND SO SHE WAS
EARNEST ABOUT YOU. JUST HAPPY
TO GET YOU UP HERE FOR MYSELF.
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW YOU MADE
YOUR MOM PROUD. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO SENATOR
NIELSEN. LATER DOWN THE SENATE
THIS JODY HAND BARNETT IS THE
EPITOME. OF WHAT THE SENATE IS
ALL ABOUT. DIGNITY
PROFESSIONALISM AND
FRIENDLINESS AND TRADITIONS
I'VE BEEN HERE A LONG TIME AND
I HAD THE PLEASURE HAVE HAVING
BEEN HERE WHEN HE WAS AROUND
THE FIRST TIME. AND HE WILL NOT
FOUND IN THE FIRST TIME. SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OTHER PRETTY
WELL AND I'VE WATCHED THROUGH
THE YEARS HOW HE HAS WATCHED
OVER NOT ONLY US THE MEMBER.
BUT THE INTEGRITY OF THE ENTIRE
INSTITUTION. WHICH IS OF THE
PEOPLE. AND WHAT IS THE SENATE
AND WHY IT IS GREAT. THIS MAN
IS IN THE PITY ME OF THAT JODY
THANK YOU WE WISH YOU GODSPEED
OUR FRIEND AND LET'S STAY IN
TOUCH. THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
SENATOR PAN. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS I TO WHY DO
I THINK- JERRY BARNETT FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP OF AN
AMAZING TEAM OF SERGEANTS I'VE
WATCHED THEM HANDLES THE PRETTY
DIFFICULT CROWDS AS THE CITY
CENTER REPRESENTS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I KNOW YOU'VE HAD TO
GIVE- SOME PERSONAL ATTENTION
TO BOTH MYSELF AND MY STAFF I
DON'T THINK IT'S ANYTHING DO
THE LEGISLATION OF CARE- THAT.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE-
EVERYTHING THAT YOU AND YOUR
TEAM HAS DONE I THINK CERTAINLY
THE EXCELLENCE THAT WE SEE AND
ARE SENATE SERGEANTS AND THE
OTHER PARTNERS- STEMS FROM YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND I JUST WANT
PERSONALLY GIVE THANKS ON
BEHALF OF. MY OFFICE AND MY
STAFF MYSELF FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST YOUR
pRETIREMENT. THE USER PAN
CENTERS GET. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I WANTED TO
STAND IN I THANK JUDY ALSO
BECAUSE WHEN I HAD HEARD ABOUT
YOUR RETIREMENT AND DIDN'T SEE
WHEN WE RETURNED- FOR AFTER
SESSION AT THE MY GOODNESS ARE
WE GOING TO NOT GET TO SEE JODY
AGAIN BUT I'M SO GLAD WE ARE
BEING ABLE TO EXPRESS OUR
PATIENT ON THE FLOOR IN SEE YOU
IT AND LOW DOCTOR PAN I. HE GOT
SOMETIMES. MORE SERGEANTS FOR
VARIOUS ISSUES AND- I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS THAT THE
COMPORTMENT OF YOU AND THE
STAFF WAS ALWAYS INCREDIBLE AN
EXCELLENT AND DURING AT LEAST
IN MY COMMITTEES WHERE THERE
WERE FOLKS THAT WERE VERY
EMOTIONAL LEGITIMATELY VERY
EMOTIONAL AND POTENTIALLY- IN
MOVES TO BE MUCH MORE
DISRUPTIVE THAN WE MIGHT HAVE
WANTED THE SERGEANTS ALWAYS
HANDLED THEM WITH RESPECT. AND
NEVER I'M AGGRAVATED THE
SITUATION AND I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATED IT AND WANTED TO
EXPRESS THAT THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER SPENDER MITCHELL. IT
KAMALA PRESIDENT LISTEN ALL
OVER AGAIN I SPOKE AT LENGTH
THE FIRST RETIREMENT SO I WON'T
BORE YOU WITH THE SAME SPEECH
BUT I DO HAVE IT- BUT BUT AS
YOUR FRIEND OF TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I WAS VERY PROUD THAT YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
BACK AND EXERCISE YOUR
LEADERSHIP WINGS AND SERVICE
OUR CHIEF STARTED SLOWING
CONGRATULATE YOU AGAIN ON YOUR
RECORD WITH TIME. AND DID YOU.
THANK YOU MITCHELL SENATOR DODD.
YES THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT ON
THE FLOOR OF TALKED ABOUT THE
GREAT WORK THE JODIE'S DIED
AROUND HERE IN HIS TEAM OF
COURSE. AND I FOR ONE HAD NOT
HAD THAT LONG OF AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH JODIE BUT ONE OF
THINGS I WANTED TO BRING UP IS
WHAT A GENTLEMAN THE IS. WHAT A
GREAT GUY JUST A GREAT HUMAN
BEING AND I'VE REALLY REALLY
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU AND
BEST OF LUCK THE TIRE THANK
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
DRAW. I WHAT AS A NEWBIE I
DON'T HAVE STORIES OF. DECADES
AGO WHEN AS LONG AS YOU BEEN
SERVING HERE BUT AS A NEWBIE.
ON HAVING COME HERE THE FIRST
DAYS WHEN THERE WAS NOBODY
AROUND. AND WE'RE GETTING OUR
ORIENTATIONAND TRAINING AND
STUFF YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN SUCH A
CLASSY. LEADER OF THIS-
BUILDING AND ALL THE PEOPLE SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. ALL
YOUR GENTLE BUT FIRM STRONG
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU CENTER
DORADO SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WELL CHIEF I
GUESS IT'S TIME. AND I I'D LIKE
TO TELL EVERYONE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR IN THOSE- IN THE BACK
THAT WHEN SOMEONE WALK SHE
WALKS IN FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME IN YOUR HOME IN YOUR JOB
WHATEVER THERE'S ALWAYS ONE
VISUAL THERE THAT WILL STAND
OUT TO WELCOME YOU. FIRST MAPS
PRO TEM YOU'RE RIGHT ON TOP OF
THAT LIST BUT JODY I GOT TO
TELL YOU YOU HAVE- WELCOME ME
AND ALL IN CLASS AND I KNOW
EACH AND EVERYONE OF ITS IS
LOVE YOU DEARLY FOR THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE. AND HAVING BOND
FOR A GROUND I SEE AS A POLICE
THE SENATE YOU'VE DONE EXACTLY
THAT YOUR GREAT MAN AND I'VE
GOT LOVE YOU AND GOD BLESS YOU
FOR EVER YOU'RE GONNA DO IN THE
FUTURE BUT YOU'RE STILL OUT A
LOT THEY HAD YOU ENJOY TODAY
HAVE A GOT. THANK YOU. ARCHER
FIRST OF OUR CHIEF URGES THE
PROP RECOGNITION THANK YOU SEE
FAR BARNETT
. FOR THANK YOU
CENTER ATKINS THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO HAVING ALL OF THOSE IN THE
PICTURE COME TO THE BAR IT
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR LAURIE
IT WILL IT NEVER MIND IT WOULD
NOT SHE'S HAPPY. THEY WERE OUT.
BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. YEAH.
RIGHT UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR SENATOR JACKSON BUT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES FROM
ONE. CALL PERSON WITH A LARGE
FOR USE TO A GROUP OF NOT SO
TALL. WOMEN WITH ALSO A VERY
LARGE MAURICE I AM HONORED AND
PRIVILEGED TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-CHAPTER OF HADASSAH. HADASSAH
IS A GROUP OF. STRONG WILLED
GREAT JEWISH WOMEN THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG HE KNOWS
WHERE HIS BREAD IS BUTTERED.
WHO HAVE TAKEN. THE STRONG
COMMITMENT OF TIKKUN OLAM WHICH
IS A JEWISH PHRASE TO HEAL THE
WORLD. AND TURNED IT INTO A
VIBRANT COMMITTED ORGANIZATION.
THAT IS JOINING US TODAY FOR
THEIR LOBBY DAY AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY HAPPEN LOBBY CHIPS WAIT
YOU'LL LEARN TO SAY YES
WHATEVER IT IS YOU WANT.
BECAUSE THEY ARE RELENTLESS AND
THEY ARE COMMITTED TO THE CAUSE
OF JUSTICE. DID TO THE CAUSE OF
COMPASSION WHICH INDEED IS THE
TRANSLATION OF THE WORD
HADASSAH. THE ORGANIZATION
BEGAN IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN IS A
SMALL MISSION OF TWO NURSES
SENT TO PRE STATE ISRAEL TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY CARE TO
INFANTS AND MOTHERS. BY
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN A MERE FIVE
YEARS LATER DAS I HAD SENT AN
ENTIRE MEDICAL UNIT COMPRISED
OF FORTY FIVE DOCTORS. NURSES
DENNIS AND SANITARY WORKERS TO
BRING AMERICAN STYLE MEDICAL
CARE TO THE MIDDLE EAST THE
ORGANIZATION HAS FOREST FOR
OVER A CENTURY INTO TO WORLD
CLASS MEDICAL AND RESEARCH
CENTERS BASED IN JERUSALEM.
THERE ARE NOW THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
NATIONWIDE AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
WHICH GOES FROM SANDWICH OBISPO
DOWN THROUGH SAN DIEGO. AND I
AM HONORED I HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT I AM INDEED A LIFETIME
MEMBER OF ASA. I WAS MY MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS OF IS A
VOLUNTEER ONLY ORGANIZATION
THEY HAVE. BEEN FIGHTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CREATING A TASK
FORCE TO TRY TO EDUCATE PEOPLE
ON THE ON THE SEVERITY AND THE
SCIENCE OF THIS CRITICAL CRISIS
THEY HAVE ALSO WORKED TO PUT IT
TO WORK ON THINGS LIKE
EDUCATIONAL WOMEN'S HEALTH.
MAKING SURE THAT WOMEN REALIZE
THEIR POTENTIAL IS A DYNAMIC
FORCE IN AMERICAN SOCIETY SO
TODAY THEY ARE HERE TO MEET
WITH US TO ADVOCATE ON VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES SUCH AS
WOMEN'S HEALTH. REASONABLE GUN
REGULATION HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND THE PINK TAX. THE PINK TAX.
YOU'LL YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE LATER. FIRST
PLEASE JOIN ME IN EXTENDING A
WARM GREETING A SENATE GREETING
TO THIS GREAT ORGANIZATION. THE
HADASSAH OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON'S. MEMBERS WE ARE STILL
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOORS
SENATOR BRADFORD I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY WE'VE BEEN ALL
VISITED PRIVATE DAY BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- THAT
REPRESENT VARIOUS PARTS OF OUR
DISTRICT AND I'M HONORED TO
HAVE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT. ARE INSIDE THE THIRTY
FIFTH SENATE DISTRICT BUT I
HAVE SPECIAL GUEST UP IN THE
GALLERY- PRESENT IT KEEP CURRY-
DOCTOR KEEP CARRIES A PRESIDENT
OF COMPTON COMMUNITY COLLEGE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT WAS IN
RECEIVERSHIP FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS AND NOW THEY'VE GOT FULL
ACCREDITATION UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP WE ARE OF OCT. OR
TRUST. PARK AND WE HAVE STUDENT.
STEVE WILL LEAVE LEASE SO GIVE
THEM AROUND APPLAUSE FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY AND GREAT
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING AND
FIVE SENATOR. WELCOME TO YOUR
CAL. STATE SENATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD. MEMBERS
MESSAGES THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
BUT WE DO PARDON ME SENATOR
CHIANG FOR PURPOSE YOU RISE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY WE HAVE NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT LEADERSHIP ACADEMY
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY UP
THERE. NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY. COLLEGE DISTRICT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT HAS ESTABLISHED A
DISTRICT WIDE LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY PROGRAM TO DEVELOP
EMPLOYEES POTENTIAL IN ORDER TO
POSITIVELY AFFECT STUDENT
SUCCESS IN INSTITUTIONAL
TRANSFORMATION. EACH YEAR
THIRTY EMPLOYEES ARE ADMITTED
TO THE PROGRAM AFTER
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION PROCESS
THE LEADERSHIP ACADEMY
RESTRICTS THE EXISTING
STRENGTHS AND EXPERTISE THAT
ALL OF ITS EMPLOYEES BRING TO
THE DISTRICT. THE ECONOMY ON
THOSE STRENGTHS OFFERING THE
PROJECT BASED APPROACH TO
DEVELOPING NEW PRACTICES FOR
ADVANCING THE DISTRICT MISSION
VISION AND GOALS. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN ON A PLUS TO CELEBRATE OF
THE HARD WORK. THANK YOU SO
CHIANG WELCOME TO YOUR CAL
STATE FOR. SENATOR ALLEN WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE MEMBERS I
UNDER PROVISIONS THE FLOOR I
JUST WANTED TO. BRIEFLY
KNOWLEDGE TODAY IS THE SEVENTY
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY THE
LIBERATION OF AUSCHWITZ. IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. YOU KNOW THE
SIX MILLION JEWISH MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN MURDERED IN THE
HOLOCAUST OVER ONE MILLION OF
THEM PERISHED AT THAT ONE
PARTICULAR DEATH CAMP ALONE.
BOTH IN SYMBOL AND IT IMPACT US
IF IT'S REALLY TRULY REPRESENTS
THE WORST. OF HUMANITY IT WAS
THE IT'S THE GREATEST SINGLE
MASS MURDER SITE. IN HUMAN
HISTORY. SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
AFTER THE LIBERATION OF THE
CAMP BY SOVIET FORCES SADLY OUR
COLLECTIVE MEMORY OF THIS
ATROCITY IS FADING. A RECENT
STUDY REVEALED THAT TWO THIRDS
OF MILLENNIALS DO NOT KNOW WHAT
OUTFITS WISE. IN ALMOST A
QUARTER HAVE NEVER EVEN HEARD
OF THE HOLOCAUST. THIS IS ONE
OF THE MANY REASONS WHY THE
LIST OF JEWISH CAUCUS BELIEVES
THAT IT IS ESSENTIAL AND
COMPELLING. TO BRING HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS. STREETS WITNESSES TO
UNCHECKED. TO THE STATE CAPITAL
FOR A REMEMBRANCE CEREMONY
EVERY YEAR SO THAT WE AS A
LIVING BODY. EACH BECOME
AMBASSADORS FOR THEIR STORIES.
TRAGICALLY TODAY WE FIND
OURSELVES IN THE MIDST OF A
RISING HATE MOTIVATED VIOLENCE
TARGETING CHOOSE ANOTHER
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT AMERICA MURDERS IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE PITTSBURG POWER
AWAY JERSEY CITY MANSI. VIOLENT
ASSAULTS IN NEW YORK AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY COMMITTED BY PEOPLE
WHO BUY INTO THE SAME ANTI
SEMITIC NARRATIVE FROM THREE
QUARTERS OF A CENTURY AGO. THAT
HELPED US IN SIX USED THEIR
DEATH. ONE OF MY MOST DAYS OF
MY LIFE WAS SPENT WALKING THE
GROUNDS OF THE AUSCHWITZ
BIRKENAU. CAMP AND I'M NOT A
SUPERSTITIOUS MAN BUT THERE THE
PLACE IS FILLED WITH GHOSTS- IT
WAS A POWERFUL EXPERIENCE AND
THEN LEAD A DELEGATION OF
LEGISLATORS JUST A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO TO. IS WHERE WE WERE
ABLE TO GET A SHAMAN EASY AND
MEMORIES COST. LEARN ABOUT THE
ATROCITIES IN ALSO CELEBRATE
THE- EXTENT TO WHICH TO MOVE
PAST. THAT DARK HISTORY. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE CONTINUES
TO BE SO MUCH THAT WE NEED TO
COMBAT. IN THE AREA OF ANTI
SEMITISM AND FEATURED. AND SO
TODAY ON THE MOMENTOUS
ANNIVERSARY OF THE LIBERATION
OF AUSCHWITZ AS WE CELEBRATE
THAT THAT MOMENT. THE FACT THAT
THOSE THE CIVILIZED WORLD CAME
TOGETHER TO DEFEAT THE ****
SCORCH. AS IN SAYS HISTORY
INCHES AWAY FROM. THE WHOLE
ACOSTA TEMPORARILY. WE REAFFIRM
OUR SOLEMN COMMITMENT TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF CALIFORNIANS
AMERICANS AND FELLOW HUMAN
BEINGS TO ENSURE THAT WE EMBODY
THE PROMISE OF NEVER AGAIN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR MITCHELL
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY PLEASE PROCEED-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
AYE IN THE THIRTIETH AND
DISTRICT OF REPRESENTING THE
SIMON WIESENTHAL CENTER. AND
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS FLOOR ON
ANNIVERSARY SUCH AS THIS ABOUT
THE NEXT GENERATION AND THE
NEXT GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO DON'T KNOW THEIR HISTORY. I
HAVE TO SAY THAT OUR I EIGHT IT
IT. I WAS GONNA SAY WARMS MY
HEART BACK IF IT DOES WARM MY
HEART- ANY DAY OF THE WEEK THAT
I'M DRIVING DOWN PICO DRIVING
WEST ON PICO THAT I'VE SEEN
SCHOOL CHILDREN LINED UP. TO
GET INTO THE FAMILIES INVOLVED.
WHICH IS NOT. A LIGHT AND
FANTASTIC SCHOOL FIELD TRIP.
IT'S A FIELD TRIP THAT WOULD BE
IT'S A FIELD TRIP THAT I
BELIEVE WHAT FEEL CHIP SHOULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND APPLY- YOUR
SCHOOL TEX LEARNINGS TO
COMMUNITY BASED EXPERIENCE A
LEARNING. AND SO I AM HOPING
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS A STATE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FUND SPACES AND
PLACES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE TO BE REMINDED OF
HISTORY ON BOTH THE GOOD AND
THE PAINFUL BECAUSE WE DON'T
MAKE KNOW OUR HISTORY. WE ARE
SUBJECT TO MAKE THOSE STEAKS
AND SO WE AS OTHER GUARDIANS IN
SO MANY WAYS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE CAN'T
FAULT THEM FOR NOT KNOWING IF
WE HAVEN'T TAKEN THE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THEY DO. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL JACKSON. I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP IN THERE FOR
A MOMENT BECAUSE- I'M OFTEN
STRUCK BY A STORY THAT I
LEARNED. WHEN AUSCHWITZ WAS IT
JUST BEFORE WAS LIBERATED THE-
THIRD REICH DECIDED THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO TRY TO WALK THOSE
WHO HAD SURVIVED ON A DEATH
MARCH. THEY TOOK FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND THEY
MARCHED THEM THROUGH POLAND.
HOPING THAT THEY WOULD DIE
ALONG THE WAY SO THAT THEY
WOULD NOT BE. THE VOICE OF
HISTORY WHEN THE THIRD REICH
ENDED. AN I REMEMBER A STORY
THAT I HEARD AND AGAIN WE ARE
LOSING THOSE WHO WERE THE
VICTIMS THEY'RE DYING. THE OLD-
AND AS A RESULT WE HEAR YOU
YOUNG PEOPLE AND OTHERS WHO
DENY THE HOLOCAUST EXISTED. NOW
REPLACING THAT VOICE WITH THE
VOICE OF THE NILE WITH THE
VOICE OF HATRED. WITH THE VOICE
OF DE HUMANIZATION BECAUSE THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN KILL EACH OTHER
IS IF WE DE HUMANIZE THE ENEMY.
THEY'RE NOT PEOPLE THEY DON'T
HAVE CHILDREN THEY AREN'T
SOMEONE'S CHILDREN THEY ARE TO
BROTHER A MOTHER OR FATHER. BUT
THIS STORY. BURKE WITH ME IS
STUCK WITH ME FOR YEARS IT'S A
STORY OF A YOUNG OF A WOMAN WAS
A YOUNG GIRL. I WAS BEING TAKEN
OFF TO. THE CAMPS AND HER
FATHER WHO WAS BEING SEPARATED
FROM HER SAID SOMETHING TO
WHERE HE SAID NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS. MAKE SURE YOU TAKE
YOUR SHOES. MAKE SURE YOU TAKE
YOUR SHOES. SHE WAS ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO WAS MARCHED.
ON THE DEATH MARCH AT THE END
OF WORLD WAR TWO IT WAS THE
FACT THAT SHE HAD CHOOSE. THE
KEPT HER ALIVE. BECAUSE OTHERS
WHO WALK THAT WALK WERE
BAREFOOTED OR WHO SHOES DID NOT
SURVIVE AND THEY THEN BECAME
SICK AND DIED OF FROSTBITE OR
THEY WERE SHOCKED. BUT IT'S A
STORY ABOUT A DAD TELLING HIS
DAUGHTER REMEMBER WHAT EVER
HAPPENS TAKE YOUR SHOES. THAT
TO ME IS PART OF THE SYMBOL OF
WHY WE MUST REMEMBER. BECAUSE
EVERY CHILD EVERY PERSON. NEEDS
TO HAVE THEIR SHOES. DOESN'T
MATTER THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
OR YOUR ETHNICITY OR YOUR
GENDER IT IS OUR COMMON
HUMANITY THERE WILL EITHER
BRING US TOGETHER SO THAT WE
ALL SURVIVE OR IT WILL DE
HUMANIZATION OF THAT HUMANITY
THAT DESTROYS US AND SO ON THIS
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY I
HOPE THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND
TEACH OUR YOUNGSTERS OUR
CHILDREN ARE FAMILY MEMBERS
REMIND THEM. THAT IT IS THE
HUMANITY THAT KEEPS US ALIVE AS
NOT ONLY A NATION BUT IS A
WORLD INTO THAT HUMANITY IS
BEING CHARGED ABOUT THE WORLD
LET US NOT. WHEN ELSE REMEMBER
WE ALL NEED THOSE SHOES THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
CENTER JONES THANK YOU MA'AM
PRESIDENT ALSO LIKE TO STAND IN
RECOGNITION THE SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY NOT SURE ON THIS
FLOOR IN THE- IN THE ASSEMBLY
SEVERAL TIMES MY- BROTHER'S EX
AND SAYS APPEARED ENGINE AND
BUT WHAT I HAVEN'T SHARED IS.
MY MOTHER. HAS IN IT FROM ME UP
PRIOR TO WORLD WAR TWO AND I
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY YET
TO TRACK BACK TO AND SEE THE
MEMORIAL THERE OR TO WASHINGTON
DC TO SEE THE MUSEUM THERE. BUT
I WAS SHOCKED ONE DAY. I AS I
WAS WALKING THROUGH THE DEL MAR
FAIR. IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY THAT
THERE WAS A TRAVELING. MEMORIAL
OF THE HOLOCAUST. AND I'VE DONE
SOME LITTLE BIT OF STUDY OF
WORLD WAR TWO IN THE HISTORY
THERE BUT- NOT A DETAILED
HISTORY OR EXPERIENCE ABOUT IT.
AND THE TRAVELING HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM REALLY WASN'T THAT BIG
MAYBE TEN PANELS AT TEN FEET BY
TEN FEET. WITH PICTURES IN AND
DISPLAYS AND. ITEMS FROM THE
HOLOCAUST OF WORLD WAR TWO. AND
TAKES MAYBE TWENTY MINUTES TO
GO THROUGH THAT TRAVELING.
DISPLAY AND IN THAT TWENTY
MINUTES THE SHOCK. AND THE
TERROR AND THE FEAR. AND THAT I
EXPERIENCED JUST FROM LOOKING
AT THE PICTURES AND
EXPERIENCING THE ITEMS THAT
WERE ON DISPLAY THERE. WAS
INCREDIBLE. AND I LEFT THAT-
THAT SHORT DISPLAY WITH WITH
TO- CHARGES FOR MYSELF IN LIFE
NUMBER ONE TO MAKE SURE THAT I
SHARE WITH OTHERS THAT
EXPERIENCE AND ENCOURAGE OTHERS
THAT WHEN THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO THROUGH A
MEMORIAL LIKE THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU GO THROUGH A MORE LIKE
THAT EXPERIENCE FOR YOURSELF.
AND NUMBER TWO. THAT I MAKE IT
A PERSONAL. CHALLENGE FOR
MYSELF TO ALSO NEVER FORGET AND
THAT HISTORY DOESN'T REPEAT
ITSELF AND WE ALL REMAIN
VIGILANT. AGAINST ATROCITIES
LIKE THIS AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
STAND AND FIGHT AGAINST THEM
BECAUSE WHEN I THINK OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS LEADERS FIVE FOR
RECOGNIZING THIS TODAY AND
GIVING US ALL AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE- WITH IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR JONES THUNDERSTORM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I DON'T ADD TOO MUCH
MORE VERY ARTICULATE WORDS HAVE
BEEN SPOKEN I JUST. THIRD ED
ONE NOTE MAYBE ONE APPEAL THAT
THESE MUSEUMS IN EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND MOMENT OF
REMEMBRANCE LIKE THIS ARE
CRUCIAL BUT WE STILL HAVE A
VERY NARROW WINDOW TO SEE
HISTORY LIVING IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES. I HAPPEN TO LIVE
WITH ONE SOME OF THE TIME IS MY
FATHER IN LAW I NEED THOSE YOU
SEE A PLUMBING TRUCK DRIVING
AROUND LA DRIVEN BY A GUY WHO
LOOKS LIKE SHOULD PROBABLY NOT
BE DRIVING THAT TRUCK FIRST OF
ALL RESTAURANT IS A VERY GOOD
DRIVER BUT YOU YOU SEE JOSH WAS
PLAN AND DRIVING A LOS ANGELES
WITH AMERICAN IT ISRAEL FLAGS
ON TOP. YOU'LL KNOW THAT VIEW
FULL STILL HANG ON SO LAST
THING I WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD
IS THAT. IS THESE TRAGEDIES
ALMOST. ENORMOUS CON. BUT THE
SIMPLE ACT OF EATING LUNCH WITH
SOMEBODY IN YOUR DISTRICT. AND
TAKING THAT SMALL INTIMATE
MOMENT AND THAT KINDA HAS TO BE
LIKE. THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR LIKE
WE GOT. A VERY VERY NEAR WANNA.
TAKE THOSE MALL MOM. BECAUSE
IT TEACHES YOU SO MUCH. ABOUT
HOW TO LIVE YOUR LIFE. IN THE
SMALL WAYS NOT JUST PREVENT THE
GENOCIDES AND THE MASSIVE WAVES
A HATRED BUT- THE TINY ACTS OF
DECENCY THE PUNCTUATE OUR DAY.
AND SOMETHING IS AS GOOD AS
LIKE ADDING NINE WELL WE SHOULD
ADD THAT MUCH BIGGER TO COUGH
BUT MY- UP WITH. NO SPOON AS-
EVER COP AND I'M LIKE WHAT A
WHAT A MILK. DIRECTED BY THE
GAS. BECAUSE IT'S THOSE BASIC.
THAT ARE STILL SPECIAL RIGHT IN
SOMEBODY'S LIFE ALL THOSE
LITTLE THINGS TAKE FOR. DAY I
HOPE OUT OF THIS DARK BEFORE.
THAT LIGHT SO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATORS. MEMBERS ANY OTHER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FOR. SEEING
NONE WE ARE GOING TO PICK UP
WHERE WE LEFT OFF MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. S.
C. R. WAS SIXTY SEVEN ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT S. C. R. SIXTY
EIGHT ITEM THIRTY FOUR SB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT. MEMBERS ALSO
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FOUR MINUTES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED WHAT BILL AND FIFTEEN
SB THREE SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MANNA PRO TEMPORE WHAT
PURPOSE TO RISE UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS MADAM PRESIDENT
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU-
MEMBERS THERE'S A LETTER AT THE
DESK REQUESTING WITHDRAWAL OF
SENATE BILL FIFTY FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE
BILL TO SECOND READING. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM SENATOR GROVE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
HAVE AN OBJECTION- FOR THAT
WITH THAT MOTION AND IT'S A
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- FOR CALIFORNIA
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
GOES TO POLICY COMMITTEE SO
THERE CAN BE ADEQUATE
DISCUSSION IN CONVERSATIONS
OVER SO WE- ASK FOR. AND THAT
NOT TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR SENATE PRO TEM IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE SENATOR
GROVE IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES NO WELL I
BORDERS NO BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CHIANG. NO DALLY NO DODD I
THEY'RE AWESOME I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL I HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. I WARLOCK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I UMBERG I LIKE
OWSKI AYE WIENER I WILK NO.
EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MOTION CARRIES MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS BILLS
ARE DEEMED READ WILL NOW MOVE
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE SENATE SECOND READING
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. FORTY FIVE THREE
SEVENTY TWO FIVE NINETY SIX SIX
FIFTY THREE SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND S CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY MEMBERS WERE
NOW MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SENATOR WILK.
PLEASE PROCEED HELP THEM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. HELP
NOTHING TO READ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS
A CONFIRMATION OF ARENA ORTEGA
AS THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MISS
ORTEGA SERVICE INSPECTOR
GENERAL IN THE OFFICE OF AUDITS
AND INVESTIGATIONS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JANUARY FIFTEENTH ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING. IT'S CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BELL I FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A AUTUMN I
CHIANG FIVE DALLY. FIVE DODD. I
AWESOME I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL I HUESO. TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I MONNING
I MORE LOCK I BROWN. I NIELSEN
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I
AM BURKE I WAKE HOUSEKEEPER AYE
WIENER I WILK HI MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROWTH. I HUESO.
I JONES HI I WAS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. SENATOR WILK PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU I MATTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS A
CONFIRMATION OF EDWARD CAMPBELL
TO THE VETERANS BOARD MISTER
CAMPBELL WAS A SENIOR AIRMAN IN
THE U. S. AIR FORCE HE IS
CURRENTLY A RESIDENT AT THE
VENTURA VETERANS HOME HE WAS
APPROVED BY BOTH COMMITTEE ON
YOU WORRY FIFTEENTH WITH A FIVE
A VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
WILK MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. I TELL I FOR
JUST I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CHIANG HI DOLLY I DODD. I
DORADO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO AYE TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. I MONEY I
MORE LOCK FIVE ZERO I NIELSEN I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN.
NUMBER FIVE WHAT CASKEY I
WIENER I WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER. STERN HI
AYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO SENATE
THIRD READING WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
CENTER PAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR PAN AN
ACT RELATED TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE COVERAGE SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SANDERS SP ONE SEVENTY FIVE
CODIFIES THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT REQUIREMENTS THAT HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS CANNOT HAVE
LIFETIME OR ANNUAL LIMITS ON
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS. SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE THREE RIGHT JUSTIN
CALIFORNIA LAW ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY ELEVEN BY REMOVING
FEDERAL CITATIONS OF PUTTING
THE ACTUAL FEDERAL LAW
PROVISIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
LAW. WITH EFFORTS TO UNDO SOME
OR ALL OF THE FOUR WHEEL CARE
ACT THIS PRUDENT THAT AT THIS
TIME TO INSURE TO CALIFORNIANS
WILL CONTINUE HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS IMPORTANT PROTECTION OF
NOT HAVING LIFETIME LIMITS I
SUSPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. AYE BATES.
AYE BELL FIVE FOR AGES I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
HI DOLLY. DODD I THEY'RE
AWESOME I GALGIANI. I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG FIVE HILL. HUESO I-
TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I
MONEY HI MORE LOCK. GROW. I
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I AM BURKE. HI MY COUNTY
FIVE WIENER. I WILK HI THIS
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DOLLY
FIVE HELLO I MORE LOCK AYE AYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN SENATOR PAM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR OH SIX BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SENATOR
PAN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS SP FOUR OH SIX ALSO
CODIFIES REQUIREMENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AT THIS
TIME TO HEALTH PLANS INSURANCE
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR PREVENTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES WITHOUT COST
SHARING LIKE THE BILL I PRESENT
EARLIER SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE
THIS BILL RE WRITES THE LAW TO
REMOVE THE FEDERAL CITATIONS
INSTEAD. PUTS IN THE ACTUAL THE
ACTUAL FEDERAL LAW VISION INTO
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW WITH
EFFORTS TO UNDO SOME OR ALL OF
THE IT SEVERAL CARE ACT IT'S
THIS TIME TO INSURE K.
CONTINUED IS IMPORTANT
PREVENTIVE SERVICES WITHOUT
COST SHARING EXPECTED TONIGHT
AT. THE DINNER PAN MEMBERS CASH
OR DEBATE THING IN HERE NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO YOU YEAH
UNANIMOUS ROLL ALL. VARIANCE
AYE SERENA NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE HOUSE. MOVING TO ITEMS.
SENT AWAY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX SO
BY SENATOR AND ACTUALLY TO PAY
UTILITY SENATOR HUESO THANK YOU
VERY PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AS BE SIX SO. THIS BILL
MAKES MINOR CHANGES TO HELP
SPEED UP THE PROCEEDINGS AND
BETTER UTILIZE ADMINISTRATIVE
IS A RESOURCES AT THE CPUC
WHILE PRESERVING PUBLIC AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WE'VE
ALL HEARD COMPLAINTS THE CPUC
PROCEEDINGS CAN BE OVERLY
ARCANE AND DECISIONS CAN TAKE
TOO LONG SPECIFICALLY SB SIX OH
FIVE WILL NO LONGER REQUIRE.
AND CONFERENCE FOR EVERY
PROCEEDING THIS BILL ALSO
REQUEST CASF LANGUAGE RELATED
TO THE EXISTING QUIET PERIODS
TO PROVIDE MORE CLARITY AFFECTS
FLEXIBILITY TO THE CPUC. THE
QUIET PERIODS OR WHERE NO ORAL
OR WRITTEN EX PARTE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE ALLOWED AND
WE'RE COMMISSIONERS CAN MEET IN
CLOSED SESSION ENDS VERY
SPECIFIED PROCEEDINGS. TODAY
THE QUIET PERIODS LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF THE COMMISSIONERS TO
SPEAK IN CLOSED SESSION JUST
BEFORE A DECISION IS SCHEDULED
TO BE HEARD AT A BUSINESS
MEETING- IMPORTANTLY SB SIX OH
FIVE MAINTAINS THE EXISTING
PUBLIC NOTICE REQUIREMENTS AND
DOES NOT CHANGE THE PRECEDING
ELIGIBILITY OF CLOTHES SECTION
SESSIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
HUESO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SITTING IN HEARING THEN
MEMBERS A CERTAIN OF XIN USING
UNANIMOUS CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN EYES THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
SENATOR STERN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES THUNDERSTORMS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- MEMBERS I
RISE PRESENT SB SEVEN FIFTY
THREE WE JUST WENT THROUGH. A
VERY TOUGH FALL- NOT JUST A
WILDFIRE SEASON BUT A SEASON
OF- RAMPANT POWER SHUT OFFS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THE VULNERABILITY
EXISTS- RIGHT RIGHT IN FRONT OF
OUR FACES WITH THE MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE. THOSE WHO WERE
IRATE CLIENTS SENIORS. WHO SENT
LEFT IN THE DARK WITH ANY NOTE
WHAT'S SO I'M NOT JUST RUNNING
THIS MEASURE FOR MY GRANDMOTHER
WHO DIDN'T HEAR- FROM HER
UTILITY THAT POWER VIçT WAS
BEING SHUT DOWN AND HAD NO.
REFERRED ME FOR HER MANY. OR
IMPACT. WOULD ALLOW BETTER
INFORMATION SHARING BETWEEN THE
COUNTY I HSS SIDE AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES BECAUSE WE'RE FINDING
THAT. THAT SORT OF HEALTH
VULNERABILITY IS REALLY THE TIP
OF THE SPEAR FOR OUR RESILIENCE
IS A STATE TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
STAY ALIVE. BOTH DURING FIRES
AND NOW DURING THIS NEW YEAR OF
POWER SHUT OFF SWITCH HAS TO
END BUT WE HOPE IS A MODEST
STEP TO- INCLUDE SOME
INFORMATION SHARING AND- PEOPLE
SAY PHILLIP NOTIFIED- SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK
YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEE. US
CENTER NIELSEN. THE A PRESENT
LAYS CHEN HEAD OF THE SENATE
THIS AN IMPORTANT. MEASURE THE-
A LAW WITH MANY OTHER RELATE TO
THIS PUBLIC SO. POWER SHUT OFF
ISSUE. L. THE DISASTER THAT
WILL BE FOLLOWED IN THE- AND-
MODE RECENT YEAR OF TRAGEDIES
SO MANY INDIVIDUALS WITH UNIQUE
NEEDS WHO ARE SERVED BY AN IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. WERE
NOT NOTIFIED. THIS IS A STEP IN
THE DIRECTION OF FACILITATING
MORE OF THEM BEING IDENTIFIED
SO THAT FOR CERTAIN THOSE MOST
NEEDY INDIVIDUALS WITH UNIQUE
NEEDS CANBE CONTACTED. THEY
INDEED ARE A HIGH PRIORITY
ARJUN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SENATOR DRAWS- FOR WHAT
PURPOSE TO RISE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- IT IS WITH REALLY
SPECIAL HONOR TO WELCOME OUR
NEWLY APPOINTED NEWLY ELECTED
LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
PRESIDENT DURING MARTINEZ. THIS
JANUARY MS MARTINEZ MADE
HISTORY AS THE FIRST LATINA TO
EARN THE ROLE OF PRESIDENT OF
THE LA CITY COUNCIL HE'S A
PROUD DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANT
PARENTS MARY WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. AND YOUR DEGREE FROM
CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE THE FIRST
IN HER HARD WORKING FAMILY TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. SHE GREW
UP IN A HOME WHERE WOMEN LED.
HER MOTHER SHOP AND TELLS THE
STORY OF HER MOTHER WORKED IN A
FACTORY ACROSS THE STREET FROM
THE HOME AND HOW THEY FOUGHT
HARD TO KEEP ITS GOOD UNION
JOBS FROM RELOCATING. NOW SHE'S
A MOTHER. AND SHE TRIES TO
INSTILL- FOURTH GRADE DAUGHTER
WITH THE MESSAGE SHE WANTS
GIRLS EVERYWHERE TO HEAR AND
THAT IS YOU CAN BE ANYTHING YOU
WANT. PRESIDENT MARTINEZ A
GLASS CEILING SHATTERING LEADER
WON ELECTION TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
ONLY WOMAN. THAT OFFICIALS IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THE AT
THAT TIME. THERE IS THE
NAZARIAN SKILL WAS CRITICAL TO
RAISING THE MINIMUM WAGE TO A
LIVING WAGE SO THAT FAMILIES A
LOS ANGELES CAN HAVE DIGNITY IN
WORK. SHE WAS ARRESTED SIDE BY
SIDE SEVERAL TIMES WITH ME AND
HOUSEKEEPERS AND DISHWASHERS
DURING NON VIOLENT CIVIL RADIUS
ACTION. A VISIONARY FROM ROOTS
NEAR A HAS PRIOR JOB CRETION
HOUSING AND THE IMPROVEMENT OF.
LOCAL SERVICES ALL WHILE
IMPLEMENTING PROGRESSIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS SHE PREPARE IT TIES
IS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AMPLE
PLACES THAT WORKING CLASS
NEIGHBORHOODS CAN BE LEFT OUT
OF THE NEW GREEN MAYES. IN
JAPAN DEREK ADDRESS IT DOESN'T
LA WILL CAN TO BE VITAL AS WE
FACE THIS. TOGETHER OF WOMEN
RIGHTS CHAMP PRESIDENT MAHER
INCREASE EFFORTS TO ASSIST
WOMEN SUFFER THE WAR OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AS A
GROUNDBREAKING ELECTED OFFICIAL
HE IS FOCUSED ON THE NEXT
GENERATION ENCOURAGING YOUNG
WOMEN TO ENTER PUBLIC SERVICE
THROUGH THE CREATION FOR READY
WOMEN. POLY I AM CREDIBLE PROUD
TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR MY FOR
LOS AND- CITY COUNCIL. NOURI
TINA'S. BUT TO GIVE A WARM
STUDENT WELCOME PRESIDENT
MARTINEZ.
ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
WELCOME IT MERRY MARTINEZ TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
THANK YOU. NEXT UP SENATORS
DINNER FILE ITEM NINETEEN. SHE
KNOWS. SKINNER SKINNER YOU
PREPARE FOR FILE ITEM NINETEEN
MOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION THE- SKINNER FOR
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO. I THINK
WE KNOW THAT EDUCATION IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT SINGLE
ACTIONS TO IMPROVE AN
INDIVIDUAL'S FUTURE. BOTH
THEIR- ABILITY TO GET BETTER
INCOME BETTER JOB ADVANCE THEIR
FAMILY YOU NAME IT. BUT PEOPLE
IMPACTED THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM STILL USED TO HER A- SO
WHILE WE ARE EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGHER ED
WITH IN BOTH OUR JAIL AND
PRISON SYSTEM WE HAVE YES YOUR
COMMUTE COLLEGES YOU SEE. ALL
OFF NOT ONLY PURSES BUT THE
PROGRAM. IN THE HIGH THE FIRST.
WE STILL HAVE COLLEGES THAT ON
MISSION CATION AT ABOUT ONE
HISTORY. NOW I IS THIS SIMPLE
TO MAKE WHAT REALLY MATTER HOW.
WHAT A NEW YORK STUDY RE. THAT
TWO OF IN THE- WITH A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE RECORD STOPPED CATION.
IT SAW THAT THE QUESTION WAS
BEING A STE THIS BIG MAMA OF
FEELING THAT IT WOULD PRESS.
THERE THEIR ABILITY TO GET INTO
SCHOOL. SO THEY JUST DIDN'T UP.
THE UCC THE CS SYSTEM OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM NO
LONGER HAVE THIS QUESTION ON
THEIR APPLICATION AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS MOVE.
THAT CHIN FROM MARK APPLET FORM
NOW. RIGHT THERE BEEN SOME
ISSUES BROUGHT UP IN COMMITTEE
ELSEWHERE AROUND THERE ARE FOR
EXAMPLE SOME GRADUATE PROGRAMS
WHERE A CERTAIN CRIMINAL
OFFENSE MIGHT PRECLUDE YOU FROM
PURSUING THEIR PROFESSION. IT
MAY BE IMPORTANT TO KNOW IN
ADVANCE SO THAT YOU WE THE
CONSUMERUP ON EDUCATE PROGRAM
KNOW THAT YOU WILL NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY POTENTIALLY TO USE
THAT TO CREATE- BUT- AND I'VE
DONE. IS WE- FINISH MISTAKE
EATING TALKED SERRA COLLEGES IN
GRAD PRO. AROUND THE OF WHAT IN
SINCE WAR CIRCA. IS THIS
QUESTION MAYBE STAY ON NASA.
DUE TO. ON PRACTICE OF THE
PROFESSION I'M COMMITTED. TO
CAN YOU BACK DISCUSSION IN
SEEING WERE TWEAKS ME NECESSARY
BUT I HOPE THAT YOU WOULD WITH
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL SO
THE WEEK GET IT OFF OF OUR
FLOOR IT WILL. COME IN CAN. BUT
WE BE IN. THE KNOW THEY CALL
PROCESS. I DO. SOME P. REYES
THE CAN. ABOUT SAVE US OFFENDER
LIVE IN A CALL DORM. NOW ARE SO
OFFENDER. ALREADY REQUIRES THAT
IF A PERSON IS EITHER IN ROLE
THAT A SCHOOL INCLUDING
COLLEGE. FOR HOT. THAT IT MUST
WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF EITHER
THEY'RE STARTING THE SCHOOL.
THEY'RE WORKING AT. THE FORM
THE SCHOOL OF THAT SIR. AND NOW
ALL OTHER RULES THAT APPLY TO
LIMITATIONS ON A SEXUAL
REGISTRANT WOULD STILL APPLY
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE ANY
OF THOSE AND AMPLE I'M STEPPING
LIKE TO. EIGHT REGISTRY IS NOT
PROTECTED UNDER FOR. THE FOR
FAIR HOW LAW SO THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT THE THOSE ARE
COMPLETELY SEPARATE FROM THE
BILL IN THE BILL DOES NOT TOUCH
ANY OF THOSE EXISTING
PROTECTION. WHICH WE HAVE. THAT
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND COMMON
GROUND AND THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND THAT THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAY BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS WERE THE NECESSARY.
ACTION WOULD SEE THAT WE ARE.
ENGAGING IN THAT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND WE'LL HAVE SOME. IN
WHEN IT COMES BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE SKINNER MEMBER
UNDER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THERE'S A FIRST ALL I
WANT TO I THINK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM BERKELEY HER WORDS ABOUT
SOME ISSUES THAT COME UP
COMMITTEE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT BUT STILL REALLY
IS ABOUT IS BEING SURE OF THAT-
PEOPLE WHO- BEEN FROM THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THREE WE GET
TAKEN THAT CAN. ISN'T AS PART
OF BEING ABLE TO. REHABILITATE
SOMEONE BE SURE THAT CAN NOW
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOCIETY. AND
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING SO
CERTAINLY I AM VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND TERMS
OF WHAT IT'S TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
I'VE AND IT THANK THE OP FOR
ACTUALLY A GAUGE IN THE STATE
PROCESS BECAUSE I THINK IT WAS
A CONCERN THAT. THERE ARE
CERTAIN- EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES IN WHICH YOU HAVE
TO BE IN SETTINGS WHERE- FOR
VARIOUS REASONS- THOSE
PARTICULAR SETTINGS ARE NOT IN
A CONDITIONAL. SETTING LIKE
CLASSROOMS BUT IN THE HEALTH.
CLINIC THINGS WHERE SOMETIMES
SOME OF THESE. ISSUES DO COME
UP AND WE WON'T BE SURE PEOPLE
ARE ABLE TO COME THE PRO. IT
COMES UP. COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL SO THAT THE AUTHORS
S. IS THAT A DRY THIS IS AND I
KNOW THAT AS THIS GOES I LOOK
FOR TO SEE WHAT COMES OUT OF
STATE CALL PROCESS BY SURLY
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL SO
THIS BILL K. THE MOVE FOR THEM
AGAIN OPPORTUNITIES EVERYONE
YOUR JOB THANK PANS PORTIS.
THANK YOU. I TO A CAN OF THE
SENATE BERKELEY IN FOR HAVING
HIS OF TO COMMENTS AND
RECOMMEND IN THE- I THINK YOU
HAVE A WRECKED FOR THAT IT'S
EARNED. WHEN I THIS BIKE. US
THAT THERE COULD A SECOND SIDE
TO THIS POINT WHERE YOU WANT TO
LOOK UPON THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AS A WAY UP FOR
THESE PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WHO
MAY HAVE HAD SOME CRIMINAL
HISTORY. THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT
COIN. MY CONCERN IS THAT YOU
MIGHT ALSO BE CREATING
CHALLENGES FOR THE SCHOOL OR
THE UNIVERSITY. THAT IS
WELCOMING THESE INDIVIDUALS IN.
THROUGH ITS BLIND PROCESS. THEY
THEMSELVES COULD BE EXPOSING
THEMSELVES TO- THE PROSPECT OF-
CIVIL LIABILITY FOR ANY
POTENTIAL MISDEEDS THAT THEY
MAKE. COUNTER FOR EXAMPLE SOME
OF THE HISTORY OF PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE WE TALKED ABOUT THE
SEXUAL ARE ART HISTORY AS WELL
YOU'RE WORKING RIGHT NOW. MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE NEED TO
PROBABLY CONSIDERED TAX THE HAS
TO ORIGIN FIRST. WELL AS THE
DIGITAL ARE GOING TO THESE.
SETTINGS DO THEY NOT HAVE A
RIGHT TO STORE THEM WITHIN TO.
NOT WHO ARE MINOR BUT THOSE
EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE A
HUSBAND A FATHER A MOTHER A
WIFE WOULD WANT O KNOW THAT
DAY OR X. BEING EXPOSED- INTO A
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS SITUATION
THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO IS THE IDEA THE
UNIVERSITY. IN THE STUDENT AND
IF THEY HAVEN'T EXTENSIVE
ENOUGH CRIMINAL HISTORY MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO FOR EXAMPLE GO TO
LAW SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
PASSED THE CARE FITNESS ROOM.
SO THEY MAY BE WAY INTENTIONED
AND IN FOR THE STUDENT THAT THE%
COULD CREATE PROBLEMS DE THE
ROAD. IN WHICH CASE- THE
UNIVERSITY BE GLAD TO TAKE
THEIR TUITION DOLLARS BUT THEY
MAY HAVE A ZERO CHANCE OF
PASSING THE CHARACTER FITNESS.
ARE OUT FOR A RESPECTED
PROFESSION OTHER BE LEGAL OR
MEDICAL OR OTHERWISE SO. I AM
I'M SORRY I KEEP FORTY ON A
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT I
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND MADE COULD SUPPORT IN THE
NEXT GO AROUND AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
YOU CENTER BOARD SENATOR. HOPE
YOU PUT YOU DOWN GOOD MEMBERS
FURTHER. OR DEBATE. THIRTY BEEN
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL. THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED IN
THE DISCUSS WAS REYES WERE THE
ONE WAS EXACT IN THE NAY OF
THAT WHICH BOTH TO A THE
COMMITTEE. AND BROUGHT UP TO ME
AS I TALKED TO MEMBERS AND SO
THAT IS WHY MY STAFF IS ALREADY
INITIATED A STAKEHOLDER MEETING
WITH COLLEGES INCLUDING
PROPERTY COLLEGES TO DISCUSS
THOSE VERY ISSUES AND- WHEN I.
HOPE THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND I HOPE THAT ARE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS GETS. IT RIGHT WHEN WE
BRING IT BACK TO. WITH THAT I
ASKED A VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER. MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARE TO.
I ATKINS. AYE BATES. WELL I FOR
JUST. NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM. I CHIANG I DOLLY NO DODD
I TO RUSSELL I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I CAN. I GROWTH. NO I
HELLO FIVE HUESO AYE TADO I AYE
JONES. LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONNING AYE MORE
LOCK NO BROWN NO NIELSEN. NO
HAN I PORTANTINO. ROTH I RUBIO
I STERN FIVE I'M BURKE I HOUSE
HE- I WIENER. I WILL. I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT. BATES JONES.
PORTANTINO. EYES THIRTY NO SIX
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SENATOR WIENER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY ONE BY SENATORS WIENER
AN ACT RELATING TO AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICTS SENATOR WIENER I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES SB TWO
WITH THE WIND- IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT WOULD PERMANENTLY BAN
GUNS SHOWS AT THE CAL PALLETS.
WHICH IS OUR STATE AGRICULTURAL
FAIR GROUNDS- ON THE BORDER OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN DALY CITY.
THIS SIDE BILL WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AND I ARE BRINGING IT BACK. FOR
DECADES HELP. HAS HOSE GUNS.
DESPITE OUR ABROAD. IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AT THE THAT
THOSE COUNTRIES SHOULD NOT
HAPPEN- WE HAVE- BROAD SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL I UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE MAYOR
OF SAN FRANCISCO. DALY CITY
COUNCIL THREATENING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SO FORTH I AFTER
MANY MANY YEARS ABOUT ADVOCACY
THE CAL. TO RENEW THE CONTRACT-
WITH THE GUN GO PROVIDER. I
GONNA LAY I'M CERTAIN THAT
GROUPS LIKE THE ARE NAY HARPER
INTENSE ON THE CAL FOR THE-
THREE AND THE GUN SHOWS AND WE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS BAND IS
IN THE PERMANENT THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. DOES NOT
ONE THESE AND SO I'M BACK I
WHAT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
RESPONSE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HONOR THAT DIRE. YEAH. THANK
YOU SO WINNER DISCUSSION DEBATE
SENATOR. MADAM PRESIDENT LAYS
DE THE SAN THIS BILL AND THIS
OPPOSITE AS LONG STAND. GOES
BACK IN MY MEMORY TO EVEN.
THESE. SERVICES LIKE THE COW
PALACE ARE AGRA DISTRICTS. AND
THE- IS ATTEMPT TO POLITICIZE
THE DISTRICTS IN THE IN MùT
OF OUR SENATE THE SENATE
ASSEMBLY DE WE DO HAVE A
INDUSTRY. SO IF THERE ARE SO
LOCAL CONCERNS ABOUT WHY. THEN
WHY SHOULDN'T THEY BE
POLITICIZED TO ANDTHINGS BE
BANNED FROM THOSE FACILITIES.
THESE THE TALK ABOUT THE GUN
SHOWS NOW I CAN UNDERSTAND THE
PHILOSOPHIC VERSION OF PEOPLE
AROUND WHERE THE CAP YEARS I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THAT'S
PHILOSOPHIC. CRIMINALS DO NOT
GO TO GUN SHOWS TO GET THEIR
GUNS FOLKS. DON'T BE WORRIED
ABOUT THAT THAT IS NOT THE
ISSUE IT IS SIMPLY A
PHILOSOPHIC POLITICAL POSITION.
AND WE ARE JUST STAY OUT OF IT
AND IT DOESN'T JUST AFFECT THE
COW PALACE THIS WILL SET
PRECEDENT FOR OTHER
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS
ACKERMAN- VOTE CENTER NIELSEN
MEMBERS FOR DISCUSS OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING ANSWER
WINNER WHICH I TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM I RISK ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER WE
MENEM'S PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARE TO. I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO WELL I FOR JUST. NO
BRAD. I HAVE A- CHECK. NO DOLLY
NO DODD I DERIVE SO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW
NO HERTZBERG. HI HELLO AYE
HUESO. FIVE I JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL.
I MONNING I MORE LOCK NO. NO
NIELSEN NO HAN I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I
AM BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI. FIVE
WIENER FIVE WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CABALLERO
NO. ROTH. BY TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
ELEVENTH THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
PORTANTINO NOT AT HIS DESK FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO SENATOR PAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS WILL FIRST- ON BEHALF
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IT'S MY
HONOR TO PRESENT SR SIXTY EIGHT
RECOGNITION OF LUNAR NEW. GEN
COOPER. THE YOUR BEGAN THIS
PASS SATURDAY GENERATOR FIFTH
WELCOME THE YEAR OF THE RAT
THIS YEAR'S PREDICTED TO BRING
PROSPERITY STRENGTH AND LOCK
THE YEAR THE RAT MARKS THE
START OF THE TWELVE YEARS YAK
CYCLE IS BORN UNDER ANIMAL SIGN
ARE KNOWN TO BE SMART DOUBLE
ALERT OUTGOING FACT JUST
TERRIBLE STORY ABOUT THE RAT IS
THE FIRST ANIMAL OF THE ZODIAC-
FORTY NINE GINS ARE THE TEMPER
RACE AMONGST THE- AND THE
KNOWING THAT LET SORT OF BORED.
ACTUALLY HITCHED RIDE ON THE-
AND AS THE WHO IS A THE LEAD
APPROACH THIS LINE LET. THE
AXIS HEAD AIM THE NORMAL THE
ACT BY THE- SO WE ALWAYS
ADMIRED THE CLEVERNESS IN
INGENUITY. THEN NEW YEAR'S A
FIFTY THE DAIS SICK BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RESULT OF
LET'S CHAN BY THE PRIVILEGE
**** AND TOO MANY A AMERICANS
IN OUR STAY LUNAR YEAR TWO THE
MOST IMPORTANT HOLIDAY OF THE-
AND MY WIFE REMINDS ME OF THAT.
MILLIONS OF.INCLUDED SPEND
CA TIME CELEBRATE I'D LIKE
TO SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
TRADITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
NEW YEAR. SO ON YOUR DESKS HERE.
YOU WILL FIND IN THE PACKAGE
AND MANDARIN AND ORANGE FRUIT.
THE FAMILY IS SYMBOLIC IN ASIAN
CULTURES THE ROUND SHAPE OF THE
ORANGE AND MANDARIN SIGNIFIES
FAMILY UNITY AND SCHOOL IN
COLOR REPRESENTS WEALTH YOU'RE
JUST GIVEN AS A GESTURE OF
GOODWILL. CHILDREN AND
UNMARRIED ADULTS ARE ALSO GIVEN
RED ENVELOPES. CONTAINING MONEY
FOR GOOD LUCK RED IS THE COLOR
OF CELEBRATION IN MANY ASIAN
CULTURES. FORTUNATELY THE
ENVELOPES IN YOUR PACKAGES DO
NOT GET THE MONEY BUT THEY DO
CONTAIN FESTIVE HOLIDAY CANDY
WHAT CANDY WHICH PRINTED WITH
CHARACTERS FOR GOOD FORTUNE AND
WEALTH. AND YOU FIND ME IN THE
PHOTO THIS YEAR'S. ANIMALS KEEP
THIS OF THE NEW YEAR WITH. AS
WE WERE IN THE YEAR THE THANK
ALL YOU TO JOIN THE MANY LOCAL
FESTIVITIES IN YOUR DISTRICTS
THAT WILL CONTINUE ON PRICE FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS. THE NEW
YEAR CELEBRATIONS INTO MUSIC
CROSS CALIFORNIA ILLUSTRATE OUR
STATE RICH CULTURE HISTORY
DIVERSITY. SO I ASKED THAT WE
PLEASE JOIN THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LET'S LEAVE CAUCUS AND
WISHING EVERY CALIFORNIAN A
HEALTHY AND PROSPEROUS YOUR BY
VOTING ON IT SR SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR PAN
MEMBERS DISCUSS OR DEBATE
CENTER. THANK YOU MAY PRESIDENT
I RISE AS A CO AUTHOR IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. SIXTY EIGHT.
AND ALSO AS A MEMBER OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND AS THE ONLY
ASIAN AMERICAN AND LEGISLATURE
I WANTED TO JOIN SENT PAN. AND
WISH TO A HAPPY NEW YEAR AS
WELL. THIS IS I'M FIRST OF TIME
WITH FAMILY AND SO THE GOOD
FORTUNE WE WILL BE JOINED HERE
AND I CONSIDER ALL OF YOU. PART
OF MY FAMILY SO THEY YOU SO
MUCH. WHICH EVERYONE A HEALTHY
PROSPEROUS NEW. THANK YOU SO
CHIANG. ANY FOR DISCUSS OR TO.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MEMBERS
AS ANY. TO USING. ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE I THIRTY NINE KNOWS.
THE RESOLUTION IS A- WE'RE TO
BACK TO FOLLOW TWENTY. SENATOR
PORTS. MADAM SO PLEASE OUR
SKEWS ME PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOR SEVENTEEN SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AN ACT RELATING TO
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK.
PRESENT THERE'S YES. SEVENTEEN
A AN URGENT MEASURE APPROACH. A
HUNDRED AND 360-007-0080
DOLLARS. THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD
FOR THE PAYMENT OF A CLAIM
RELATED TO AN A RONI IS FICTION.
NAIL TAG. THE EIGHT AND A BORE
AND THE BOARD WITH THE COURT TO
THAT SHE WAS INNOCENT OF AN-
FROM CA. A THE BOARD.
COMPENSATION FOR NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN DAYS OF
INCARCERATION RELATED TO THAT
CONNECTION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS APPROVED THE
PAYMENT AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
CLINTONS' BELTS THAT TRADITION
HAS THE APPROPRIATIONS.
CARRYING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO SENATOR JACKSON'S.
AS IN I HAVE NEVER STOOD UP IN
UPPER. TO ONE OF THESE CALL BUT
THIS ONE IS A INTERESTING THE
CIVIL SERVICE HEARING OFFICER
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD
RECOMMENDED ONLY COMPENSATING
THE CLAIM IT. SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. YET THE
ATTORNEY SENATE DEPUTY
INTERVENE. AND PRESSURE A BOARD
OF POLITICAL APPOINTEES TO
IGNORE THEIR OWN. THING OFFICER
AND MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
COMPENSATION TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. I
CERTAINLY BELIEVE IN SECOND
CHANCES FOR THOSE WHO HAVE DONE
WRONG AND ARE SEEKING
REDEMPTION. HOWEVER IN THIS
CASE GIVING A HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS OF TAX
MONEY. TO A MATH ACT AND I FOR
THESE. I BELIEVE ARE SIMPLY
WRONG CAN I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
EXPERTISE ISSUE. SKINNER OWNS.
CENTER THE PROPOSED DECISION
THE AG OPPOSE THE REDUCTION IN
COMPENSATION BECAUSE THE TRIAL
COURT WOULD NOT HAVE RE
SENTENCED HER TO PRISON FOR THE
TWO VALID CONVICTIONS IF SHE
HAD NOT BEEN A RONI ASLI
CONVICTED OF THE ESCAPE. THE
BOARD ULTIMATELY AGREED WITH
THE AG AND DETERMINED BASED ON
A PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE
THAT TAGGART'S ARONIAN SIN CAR
SERRATION INCLUDED. THE CURRENT
PERIOD SHE SERVED FOR THOSE
CONVICTIONS AND COMMENDED THE
AND STATION IN THE AMOUNT OF A
HOT AND THIRTY SIX HOW. AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS THE NINE HUNDRED
A DAY SO IT SHORT AT ISSUE THE
AT THE- IN THE SIDE NOT THE
REDUCTION SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE. OUR OUR I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO WELL I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A LETTER I
CHIANG. DALLY NO DODD I-
AWESOME I TELL JOHNNY I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO FIVE TADO I
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I MONNING
I MORE LOCK I MORAL. NO NIELSEN
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I
UMBERG I Y. CASKEY. I WIENER
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN FIVE FOR
JUST. CHIANG GLAZER. GROWTH
WELL. EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
FIVE ON THE URGENCY EYES TWENTY
NINE KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE SENATOR
SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBER SO
OUR- PROGRAMS LIKE CAL FRESH
WHICH WE USE TO REMEMBER
REFERENCING AS FOOD STAMPS ARE
NOW ADMINISTERED THROUGH EBT AN
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TRANSFER.
ARMED ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID IN
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FARM BILL
WAS MAKE IT ALLOW FOR THE
OPTION OF USING YOUR EBT SO IN
THIS CASE CAL FRESH TYPE
BENEFIT TO ORDER FOOD ONLINE.
NOW THIS BILL WHAT IT DOES IS
ESTABLISHES A WORKING GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND OTHERS SO
THAT AS BE EXPANDING THE
OPPORTUNITY OF USING EBT FOR
ONLINE PURCHASES OF EITHER FOOD
OR EVEN PREPARED MEALS BECAUSE
NOW THE EBT BENEFITS CALPERS
BENEFITS CAN BE USED FOR
EXAMPLE FOR REST. MEAL THAT THE
EBT BENEFICIARY HAS THE SAME
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
ANOTHER PERSON WHO USED TO SAY
A CREDIT CARD OR CASH. AND WITH
THE REASON THAT WE NEED THIS IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT OF
RETAILERS ENGAGE IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY FEEL LIKE HOW I
DON'T HAVE TO. GIVE YOU BACK
YOUR EBT BENEFIT IF FOR EXAMPLE
THE FOOD WAS DELIVERED OR IT
WAS A SPOILED THE NUMBER OF
THINGS YOU WANT TO SURE THAT
THE EVEN THE WRIST YET AS THE
SAME TYPE OF CONSUMER BENNETT
SB THIRTY THREE DOT IS I MET.
IS A STAB THAT WORK GROUP THE
CAN SET UP. AND PROPOSED BACK
TO US SOME SAFE AND ETHICAL
STANDARDS FOR EBT ONLINE
PURCHASING AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
HEARING THEN EYES THIRTY NINE
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
SENATOR HERTZBERG BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO INSURANCE
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I'M CARRYING
THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY'S C. E. A- FOR THOSE
WHO KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS IN MY
OFFICE. IN ANY EVENT- THIS MATT
MISS MEASURE REPEAL CERTAIN
OBSOLETE PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE CODE
RELATING TO EARTHQUAKES STORIES
CLAIM PAYING FRAMEWORK ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THIRD
WARLOCK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST CURIOUS- IF I
COULD ASK A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. HERTZBERG WE TAKE A
QUESTION. OKAY FEDERAL PLEASE
PROCEED THE DISCO THROUGH THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. I DON'T
THINK IT DID THE DID. WHAT WHAT
SEVEN THREE SEVEN THREE THAT'S
RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT SEVERAL CASCADE
THANK YOU I REMEMBER WE ARE
MORE LIKE MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER HERTZBERG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BELL FIVE FOR JUST I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG I
DOLLY I DON. I AWESOME I TELL
JOHNNY. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG HI
HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO. HI
JACKSON I JONES. FIVE LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL I MONEY. I
MORE LOCK. MORRELL I NIELSEN.
PAN. FIVE PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH
AYE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. FIVE
STERN HI I'M BURKE I WHITE
HOUSE SKI AYE WIENER AYE WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD BRADFORD I.
MORE LOCK. I NIELSEN HI. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR WIENER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT ON A
COLLEGE GIVEN THE RECENT SURGE
IN THE NUMBER OF PLANNED
BLACKOUTS- AN IMMENSE
DESTRUCTION THAT THEY HAVE
CAUSED BY SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT- AIMS TO ENSURE-
THAT ARE LARGE UNTIL IT HE'S
USING BLACKOUTS ONLY WHEN THEY
ARE TRULY NECESSARY. AS AN
OPTION OF LAST RESORT THAT THEY
ARE USED AS A SCALPEL BUT AS A
SLEDGE HAMMER. AS YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN I PUT THIS LINE WE'RE
STILL IN THE PRINT LAST
SEPTEMBER. TO THE INTENT PLACE
OF WOULD BE THERE IF YOU. GET
SIGNIFICANT FOR WE CAME BACK IN
THE SESSION. AND WE RECEIVED A
LOT OF FEEDBACK IN THE MIDDLE
OF CHANGES TO THE BILL. WE ALSO
MADE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS-
THAT WE TALK AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE ENERGY COMMITTEE- TO SCALE
THE BILL BACK WE'RE HAPPY TO DO
THAT. WE KNOW THE BILL'S WORK
IN PROGRESS AND WE WILL. TO
WORK WITH STAKE. IN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE OPPONENTS OF
THE BELT AS WELL AS A
SUPPORTERS AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS. YEAR WHAT WILL SURELY BE
A SIGNIFICANT YEAR FOR ENERGY.
ABOUT SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT IS
A GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO TRY AND
GRAPPLE WITH THE VERY VERY
NEGATIVE IT ACTS OF THESE
BLACKOUTS ON THE FOR
CALIFORNIA. ON THE PROBLEM OF
COURSE IS MOST ACUTE IN THE GT
TERRITORY WHAT WE HAD ONE BLOCK
OUT THAT AFFECTED TWO POINT
FIVE. MILLION BUT WE KNOW THAT
IT'S AN ISSUE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. GOING TO BE
VERY CLEAR THIS IS NOT ABOUT
OPPOSING THE USE OF BLACKOUTS
TO AVOID WILDFIRES BLACKOUTS
CAN BE A POWERFUL TOOL TO
REDUCE WILDFIRES. THIS IS ABOUT
ENSURING THAT THESE BLACKOUTS
ARE NOT BROADER AND LONGER.
THAN THEY NEED TO BE AS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC SAFETY. RIGHT
NOW AND THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM. INSIDE THE UTILITIES
HAVE NO INCENTIVE HAVE NO
OBLIGATION. TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE HARM. TO PEOPLE.
BETTER CALL IS CAUSED BY THE
BLACKOUTS. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHEN PEOPL
LOSE MEDICINE OR LOSE THE
CONTENTS OF THE REFRIGERATOR.
THEY DON'T TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN THE SMALL BUSINESSES
FORCED TO CLOSE AND MAYBE GOES
OUT OF BUSINESS. IN ORDER TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE LOST
WAGES THAT SOMEONE SUFFERS
BECAUSE THEIR EMPLOYER HAD TO
CLOSE DOWN. OR BECAUSE THEY HAD
TO STAY HOME BECAUSE OUR KIDS
SCHOOL HASBEEN SHUT DOWN AS A
RESULT. OF THE BLACKOUT. HI HE
THREE SEVENTY EIGHTHS- WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE TO SEE
COMPENSATION FOR DAMAGES-
THROUGH THE CPU CITY IN THE
CITY YOU SEE WHAT FLEXIBILITY.
SET UP PROCESS MEN ARE WHAT
KIND OF DAMAGES SHOULD BE A
RECOVERABLE. IN ADDITION IF THE
CPUC THE TERM AND- THE TOP
BLOCK OUT. ON REASONABLE. IF
WELL AT LEAST. FAR BUT NOT IF
IT'S THE TO BE RES. THE BILL
WILL NOT ALLOW THE UTILITIES TO
CHARGE PEOPLE FOR A LACTIC
SERVICE DURING BLACKOUT PERIODS
AND YES. PEOPLE GET CHARGE FOR
SERVICE DURING PERIODS WHEN
THEY HAVE NO SERVICE- SO
COLLEAGUES THIS IS I THINK A
GOOD FAITH. A STEP FORWARD TO
GET A HANDLE ON THESE BLACKOUTS
IT'S A LITTLE BIT LIKE THE WILD
WEST ALL RIGHT NOW AND REAL
PEOPLE ARE BEING HARMED- LIKE I
SAID. WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS- AS WE
INDICATED IN THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. TWELVE DAYS AGO- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE COMING
MONTHS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS
IS GOOD A BILL- AS POSSIBLE
THING OBSERVERS SUPPORT RESPECT
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
PORTIS. THANK YOU. I HAD A
DISTRICT TOUR- DURING THE BREAK
IN WILD FIRE THE WILD FIRE
PRONE AREAS OF MY DISTRICT AND
I HEARD LENTY OF EXAMPLES OF
ODD DURING THE BLACKOUT- FOR
EXAMPLE SMALL MOM AND POP
RESTAURANT DIDN'T HAVE A
GENERATOR AND LOST ALL THE
SUPPLIES THAT HAD IT FOR THE
RESTAURANT ALMOST PUT BUSINESS
OUT OF BUSINESS. I THINK THERE
ARE NUMBER OF IT SINCE WERE WE
SEE BLACKOUTS AND NATURALLY
BEGS THE QUESTION WERE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY RELATED BLACKOUTS
OR ARE THERE OTHER FORCES AT
PLAY SO MY- I AM A GREAT AMOUNT
OF EMPATHY FOR THE DESIRE OF
THIS LEGISLATION MY CONCERN IS
WHETHER OR NOT GOOD POLICY IS
BEING PUT FORWARD OR IF YOU
COULD BE MADE BETTER. I REFER
TO 12-1 ELEVEN POINT FIVE AND
IS IN TURN KIND OF MUSEUM
HARPER. IF THE ISSUE BERMAN.
THE DEAL. CORPORATE FAIL TO ACT
IN A READ. IN PRUDENT MANNER.
IN ITS SIMPLE. AND EXIT. OF THE
JEEP THE D. STATION EVENTS.
WHEN I WHEN I HEAR REASONABLE
AND PRUDENT HI QUESTION ARE WE
ARE WE WERE IN SACRAMENTO RIGHT.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS I DON'T THINK I CAN THE
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY KNOWING THAT THE P.
YOU SEE IS GOING THROUGH. A
REVIEW PROCESS. AND I'M- AS
DOES THERE'S A TIME LINE ON
THIS YOU NEED TO GET OVER TO
THE ASSEMBLY LIKELY BRING IT
BACK IN THE PROCESS. NGUYEN THE
P. YOU SEE DOES COMPLETED MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT WILL
BE. INCORPORATED INTO THIS
LEGISLATION. SO NOW IT- MEMBERS
AND IF I MAY POSE A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR. FOR THAT VERY
PURPOSE. SENATOR WIENER WE TAKE
A QUESTION. PLEASE THAT SEAT IN
THAT THERE'D BE EXACTLY AT ARE
YOU ANTICIPATING THAT WHEN THE
P. YOU SEE HAS ITS FRAMEWORK
PUT FORWARD. WITH MORE
PARTICULARITY ON THE CRITERIA
USED TO DETERMINE WHETHER A-
PROVIDER ACTED REASONABLY
IMPRUDENT THAT YOU WILL
INCORPORATE THAT INTO THIS
LEGISLATION IS THAT YOUR
ANTICIPATION. YES REASONABLE
AND PRUDENT IS AN EXISTING
STANDARD TO SEE IF YOU SEE AND
THE CITY YOU SEE IS AS YOU KNOW
GOING THROUGH A BUT THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT OF COURSE. IS GOING
THROUGH A PROCEEDING TO
SPECIFICALLY DEFINE WHAT
REASONABLE AND PRUDENT MEANS IN
A BLOCK ALL CONTACTS- AND WE ON
AND DOT DOT WILL BE WHAT THE
BILL RELIES ON. AND I AND IF I
MAY KNOW SPECIFIC TO THAT
ASKER'S- DISTRICT I'VE
NEGLECTED TO MENTION BEFORE-
THAT THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
RC RC SUPPORTS THIS BILL. AND
THE FARM BUREAU HAS NOT YET
TAKEN ITS OFFICIAL POSITION BUT
HAS ENCOURAGED. THAT THE BILL
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AYE
RICE'S CO AUTHOR OF SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AN URGENT WE NEED
A BILL THAT WILL HELP DIMINISH
THE IMPACT OF MASS BLACKOUTS
FROM PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF OTHERWISE KNOWN AS P. S. P.
S. WHICH HAD BEEN INFLICTED
UPON OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
LEARNED LAST FALL THAT OUR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES ARE
NOT AS PREPARED AS THEY SHOULD
BE TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE.
BRING ONE OF THESE P. S. P. S.
ADVANCE A WHEELCHAIR BOUND.
EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD VETERAN.
WHO NEED A RELIABLE SOURCE
ELECTRICITY TO POWER HIS
GENERATOR FOR HIS OXYGEN.
CALLED HIS LOCAL UTILITY. AND
THEIR ADVICE. DIAL NINE ONE ONE.
UPON HEARING THAT SOME WOMEN
LACKEY AND MYSELF PERSONALLY
DELIVERED AND SET UP A
GENERATOR- THAT THE VETERAN USE
FOR THE FOLLOWING FIVE DAYS.
THIS IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
MASSIVE WILDFIRES ARE HORRIFIC
ENOUGH WITHOUT THE ADDED BURDEN
AND NO ELECTRICITY IF YOU LIVE
IN A RURAL AREA THIS MAY MEAN
NO PHONES OR NO WATER FOR UP TO
SEVERAL DAYS. MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS THEY DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS PS PS THEY BELIEVE
THAT IS P. S. B. S. AND I
BELIEVE SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
IS A REMEDY THAT WILL HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND WHOLE DIO
USE ACCOUNTABLE. AND AS THE
AUTHOR SAID THIS IS THIS BILL
ISN'T IS NOT COMPLETED BUT WE
NEED TO MOVE IT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO BRING ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO. TOGETHER AGAIN
A PROTECT CONSUMERS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. HANK YOU CENTER
WILK SENATOR RUBIO. MADAM
PRESIDENT. OF FIRST I JUST
WANTED TO STATE FOR THE RECORD
YOU KNOW I HAD CONVERSATONS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
AFFECTING SO MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS. ARE WE WERE ABLE TO
HEAR TESTIMONY FROM AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO LOST EVERYTHING
AND SHE WAS HELPING HER
NEIGHBORS AND SO WE RECOGNIZE
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS. TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
ALL THESE ISSUES FOR THE FUTURE
HOWEVER I STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT I NEED TO.
EXPRESS UP CHIN FOR THE- WE IN
OUR QUEST. THANK YOU PLEASE
FIRST. AS IT'S WRITTEN NOW ARE
THE HEAD OF FINES EVERY HOUR ON
THE HOUR STILL PART OF THE BILL.
I'M SORRY WE FIND SECOND HERE.
YOU QUIT ALTES YEAH YES SO THAT
WILL BE AMENDED DOT PROVISION
IN THE ENERGY COMMITTEE WERE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- WE CUT OF THE
HOURLY FEES IN HALF- AND THEY
ONLY APPLY IT SEE IF YOU SEE
HAS THE TURN OF THE BLACKOUT.
WAS ON REASONABLE SO AFTER THE
FACT- DOING INVESTIGATION MAKE
A DETERMINATION IF IT WAS A
REASONABLE BLACKOUT. THEN THE
FEES DON'T APPLY TO HOURLY
FINES IF YOU DON'T APPLY IT WAS
ON REASONABLE THEY APPLIED BUT
THEY WERE CUT IN HALF BY THE
COMMITTEE AND I WAS HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THAT AMANDA. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. I'M STILL BASED ON
YOUR STATEMENT I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS ONE OF THE THINGS I
REALLY SUCH A STRUGGLE WITH IS.
WHEN WE IMPOSE YOU KNOW ALREADY
PENALTIES AND FINES MY CONCERN
IS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SAVE
LIVES. AND THESE PENALTIES MAY
CAUSE SOME OF THE UTILITY
COMPANIES TEND TO HESITATE TO
BLINK. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
LIVES OF INDIVIDUALS WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO TAKE THAT SHORT
CUT. AND SO THAT IS A BIG
CONCERN STILL OF MINE THAT DAVE
THEY'RE TRYING TO. MEET THE
RESTORATION UNDER THAT OUR JUST
TO AVOID A FINE THAT THAT POSES
FOR ME THAT'S A CONCERN WE WANT
THE UTILITY COMPANIES TO TAKE
THEIR TIME MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO. TO
ENSURE THAT THE LINES ARE CLEAR
AND THEIR PEOPLE ARE SAFE. SO I
DID MOVE THE THAT THE BILL FORD
BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO EXPRESS
THAT THERE'S A LOT THINGS TO.
FIX AND THIS BILL AND I HOPE
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK. BOB
SURE THAT WERE. DENTAL USING
YOUR OR AT LEAST. IN THE
UTILITY COMPANY TO. THE PICKUP.
AND NOT BE SEEN. WITH WHAT
THEY'RE- IN AND SO WITH THAT. I
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- WE
ALL SHARE THOSE ISSUES THAT
TOOK PLACE WITH THESE YES YES
SHUTDOWNS- I GOT A PHONE CALL
FROM THE CITY MANAGER OF
ATTACHED BE AN ENTIRE CITY OF
JUST UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE. AND P. JEANNIE YEARS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SINCE. THE
WHICH I SHOULD MENTION THAT I
APOLOGIZE. JUST HIT THE WRONG
LINE AND IT TOOK HIM A COUPLE
OF DAYS TO GET THAT. POWER BACK
ON WE HAD HOSPITAL'S SCRAMBLING
WE HAD A WATER TREATMENT
FACILITY. SO I UNDERSTAND THE
PAIN THAT IS GOING ON I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE AFFECTED
AND THAT HAD ISSUES WITH. BEING
SHUT OFF WHETHER THEY WERE ON
OXYGEN OR HAD NO. ABILITY FOR
MOBILITY AND SO THERE ARE HUGE-
HUGE ISSUES WITH THESE SHUT OFF
SEIZE POWER THAT OFFICE. IS IF
YOU'RE NOT PREPARED ARE YOU
NOTED. SO I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC
TO THAT POINT- WE YOU KNOW OUR
PURPLE RESIDENTS WAS AFFECTED
AT ONE TIME. AND I DON'T AND
I'M NOT SAYING THAT JUST
BECAUSE OF ME I'M JUST SAYING
THAT I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO. AND HOLD UTILITY.
ACCOUNTABLE BUT WE- TO LOOK AT
THE BRIGHT PIT- OF. THE NO
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION IN
ARE GOING TO TAKE PLACE THIS
YEAR SPECIFICALLY AROUND OUR
LARGE UTILITY HOLDERS. AND%
THESE ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING.
YOU KNOW THESE WILDFIRES AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID RE. SUBSTANTIAL
AND CREATE- DEATH IN SOME CASES
IN FULL LOSING EVERYTHING. IF
THESE UTILITIES ARE GONNA BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE AT.
AND THEN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AS
TWELVE FOR ME THE GAME DâN.
THAT WORD FROM S. WHILE. I
THINK THERE HAVE A GIVE. WE
THOUGHT WHAT'S GOOD BURKE ASIDE.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S-
TO THAT WE ELIMINATE MASSIVE.
HERE'S MY SAG AND YOU GET A
LINE BREAKAGE THAT CREATE. A
SOME OF THE WILDFIRES. BUT WE
ALL HAVE TO LOOK AT VEGETA
MANAGE AND A LOT OF THINGS. THE
NEED TO TAKE PLACE IN ORDER AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT NEED TO
TAKE PLACE IN ORDER THAT WE
HAVE SUSTAINABLE ELECTRICITY.
THAT GOES AND WE DON'T END UP
LIKE A THIRD WORLD COUNTRY I
MEAN WE'RE CALIFORNIA IN THE
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY IN IN
TWENTY TWENTY. AND WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A VIABLE
SOLUTION FOR POWER MOVING
FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT HOLDING
THEM ACCOUNTABLE IN ONE PLACE
BUT NOT ALLOWED TO EXT EYES AT.
THE IN S. IT IS TO BE CALM. ON
THE MINUTES. YOUR BILL DAY BUT
I WANT YOU TO REALLY FOCUS ON.
ARE TURNING IN THE CAUCUS
BASICALLY THE REASON SALUTE YOU
KNOW THE RE. LANGUAGE THAT'S
WHAT'S REASONABLE. NO THE
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
WHAT REASONABLE IS SO WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY. HONE DOWN THAT
LANGUAGE WHEN YOU GET IT OUT OF
THIS FLOOR AND MOVE OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY. BECAUSE I REALIZE
THAT SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE
AND I HAVE A LOT OF ANGRY
CONSTITUENTS AS WELL. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT. LIKE I
SAID. YOU KNOW WERE IT'S ALMOST
AS IF WE'RE REQUIRING SOMEBODY
TO DO SOMETHING AND NOT GIVING
THEM THE ABILITY TO DO. IN
ORDER TO. IMPACT THE KEY ISSUE
IS WE SET. ASK YOU TO WORK AT
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD. THANK
YOU. DOLLY THE MATTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I DO WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT I'M GONNA LAY OFF THE BILL
TODAY AND REASON I ONE OF THE
OFFICE I THINK THAT. THE FOCUS
OF THIS BILL IS ON THE UTILITY
IN THE FOCUS I THINK IN MY
MIND. WOULD BE THE P. YOU SEE.
THEYHAVE FAILED US.
TREMENDOUSLY FAILED US. WE
AUTHORIZED THEM AND I DON'T
WANT TO GO OUT AND- MAKE SURE
THE LINES WERE SECURED AND THAT
THEY HAD. PROGRESS MOVING
FORWARD. THEY DIDN'T EVEN
FOLLOW UP AND CHECK UP THEY DID
ABOUT 5% OF THE WORK. THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE THE LAST YEAR
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO. RUN A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT. THAT
IS LOOKING AT CREATING MORE
RATE PAYER THERE'S THIS IS
GONNA BE POSITIONS. FOR THE P.
YOU SEE ACTUALLY ANALYZE THIS
BILL AND COME UP WITH IT
WHETHER IT WAS. JUSTIFIED OR
NOT. WE'RE GONNA AUTHORIZED
MORE POSITIONS WE NEED TO.
PURSUE ANALYZE THE- AGENCY THAT
IS. TO REGULATE THE UTILITIES
WHICH IS THE P. YOU SEE. AND IN
THE- EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE
WHETHER IT'S WILD FIRE WHETHER
IT'S OUR PS. THE P. YOU SEE
TAKES A STAND BACK AS IS ALL
THE LEGISLATURE NEED TO TELL TO
DO THAT WE TOLD THEM TO DO
SOMETHING. IN SB NINE A ONE AND
A FAILED US. HEARD LOUD YEAR
KNOWING FOR THE TIME THAT WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE THESE. HIGH
WINDS THAT YES WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE. MAKE SURE THAT UTILITIES
INCLUDING CELL TOWERS IN THOSE
YES THEY REPORTED BACK TO THEM
AND WHAT DID WE GET. WE GOT
POWER OUTAGE WE GOT CELL
SERVICE OUTAGE FOR DAYS ON END.
SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THE P. YOU SEE. THEY
ARE FAILING US HORRIBLY THEY'RE
APPOINTED BODY. THEY ARE NOT
DOING WHAT THEY NEED TO BUT WE
NEED TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
BEFORE WE GO GIVING THEM MORE
DISCRETION TO HIRE MORE PEOPLE
TO REGULATE UTILITIES WE NEED A
MICRO WORKS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SHUT DOWN OUR SYSTEM IN SMALL
AREAS NOT GIANTS WALLACE I WAS
FACED WITH THE SAME THINGS MY
COLLEAGUES IN MANY OF YOU
TALKED ABOUT TODAY WHERE I HAD
BUSINESSES LOSE LILY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSAND DOLLARS ALMOST PUT
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS AND
THEY'RE GONNA GET COMPENSATED.
TO LEARN FIFTY. THE A DAY
CANDIDATES RIDICULOUS. SO I'M
REALLY OFF YOUR BILL I'M GONNA
SEE WHAT COMES BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY BUT I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THIS BODY TAKE A REALLY GOOD
LOOK AT THE P. YOU SEE AND WHAT
THEIR POWERS ARE AND HOW THEY
USE THEM AND NOT USE THEM TO
THEIR FAVOR VERY DISCOURAGED
WITH THEM I THINK WE CAN DO A
BETTER JOB TO SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS IT. A LOT OF VERY
I JUST UTILITIES OF ENERGY BUT
ALSO OUR COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS THAT ARE OUT THERE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. CALLING
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR WINNER PLEASE
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT BECAUSE I WANT
TO THANK YOU- FOR THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY AND I THINK-
WHAT IS CLEAR FROM THIS
DISCUSSION IS WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO GET THROUGH THIS AND WE ALL
ARE SAYING THAT THIS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE. IS NOT-
YEARS NEVER ENERGY IN
CALIFORNIA'S NEVER CLEAR CUT-
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET THROUGH
IT THE BEST WE CAN BUT WHAT WE
KNOW. WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
THESE BLACK OUTS JUST LIKE THE
WILD FIRES ARE EXTREMELY
HARMFUL HARMFUL THE BLACKOUTS
ARE HARMFUL. AS WELL. AND THIS
IS NOT ABOUT- ABOUT. SAYING NO
WILD FIRES THIS IS ABOUT HAVING
A STRIKING A BALANCE. AND RIGHT
NOW THERE IS NO BALANCE RIGHT
NOW ALL THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR THE UTILITIES
ARE ALL ON THE SIDE OF BROADER.
AND LONGER BLACKOUTS YES THEY
LOSE SOME MONEY- BUT THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES ARE
STRONGLY ON THE SIDE OF GOING
LONGER AND BROADER BLACKOUTS.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO BRING IN
ALL THE WAY TO THE OTHER SIDE
WE'RE WE SO YOU'LL NEVER DO IT.
BY HANCE TO TAKE A MORE
BALANCED APPROACH- AND WE
ABSOLUTELY- WILL BE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS JUST LIKE WE
HAVE BEEN WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT INTENSIVELY- AND NO THIS
BILL WALKING. INTO A BALL THERE
WILL GET BETTER AND BETTER. FOR
ABOUT WORK IN IT FINALLY OUR
OKAY WITH RESPECT TO THE LAST
CALM ABOUT THE CPUC. I ABOUT.
OF FIGHTS TO CRITICISMS OF WITH
THE P. IS IMPOSSIBLE NOT MANY
OF THE- FROM THE TAP BUT- THERE
ONE DAY. I AM. THIS IS NEEDS TO
DO BUT BOTTOM AREAS WE NEED TO
VERY VERY CLEAR. THAT THE ROOT
CAUSE OF WHAT IS BECAUSE- OF
THE HOW FAR IS THE- OUT ALL THE
OTHER PROBLEMS. IT'S NOT THE
CPUC EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE NOT
DONE ENOUGH. IT IS P. JEANNIE
IN PARTICULAR- THAT HAS ALLOWED
SYSTEM. FALL APART AND THAT IS
EVERYONE IN THE TERROR. BECAUSE
WHAT ABOUT THAT I OF RESEARCH.
COLORS ARE. ASK I. THANK YOU
THERE WE- MEN'S PLEASE CALL.
THANK I DALLY. DODD I THERE
AWESOME HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
HELLO I HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON.
JONES LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. I ON BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
BATES FOR JUST. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. DALLY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG JACKSON. JONES MORE
LOCK NO AROUND. NIELSEN AMBERG.
SIZE TWENTY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
ARCHULETA. BATES FOR JUST.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. DOLLY
GROWTH. HERTZBERG JACKSON.
JONES NO MORRELL. NIELSEN I'M
BURKE THE UN SECRETARY EYES
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
GALGIANI MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GALGIANI AN
ACT RELATING TO MISSING PERSONS
CENTER GALGIANI THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB THREE
pUNIFORM REPORTING OF ALL AT
RISK MISSING CHILDREN AND
ADULTS ACROSS ALL COUNTIES. BY
LIFTING AN EXEMPTION AND
CURRENT LAW THAT ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO NOT PARTICIPATE IN
THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM IN THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND AS P.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
JACKIE'S- ESTABLISHED A DNA
DATABASE FOR ALL CASES
INVOLVING THE REPORT OF A
MISSING PERSON. AND RECOVERY OF
HUMAN REMAINS AND SB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR RAINY
ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS TO BE
FOLLOWED UPON RECOVERY OF HUMAN
REMAINS. POLICIES WORSE IS TO
ALLOW ONE FOR SENATE TO MATCH.
DN INTO SHE SAMPLES TAKEN FOR
COVER ON IDENTIFIED DECEASED
PERSONS WITH DNA COLLECTED FROM
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH MISSING
PERSONS. TODAY IN AG'S DATABASE
THERE ARE MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND SETS OF HUMAN REMAINS
THAT HAVE BEEN RECOVERED BUT
NOT IDENTIFIED AND THE PROBLEM
IS GROWING NATIONWIDE. THIS
TAKES A TREMENDOUS HUMAN TOLL
ON THE FAMILIES WHO LOVE AND
MISS THEM AND A TOLL ON THE
DEDICATED DETECTIVES WHO
CONTINUE TO PURSUE. THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS SB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT INSURERS STATEWIDE
CONSISTENCY REGARDING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HANDLING OF
MISSING PERSONS CASES ENSURES
THAT TODAY GOING FORWARD WE
GIVE FAMILIES THE BEST CHANCE
TO BRING THEIR MISSING LOVED
ONES HOME. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THE USER
GALGIANI MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SING IN
HERE THEN THIRTY NINE DOES YOUR
THE MADE THE PASSES MOVING UP
TO FIVE I TO TWENTY EIGHT. TURN.
FOLLOW A MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO FIRE PREVENTION
SENATOR STERN. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. AT SOME OF THE
MEMBERS IN THE LAST DEBATE
BROUGHT UP. PERHAPS THE MOST
CRITICAL PIECES TO PREVENTING
FIRES FROM. AFFLICTING OUR
COMMUNITIES ISN'T IS NOT SO
MUCH ABOUT. THE POWER SHUT OFFS
AND THE ISSUES WE'VE SEEN
AROUND TRY TO PREVENT THE FIRES
BUT- THE WORKING ADVANCE THAT
HAS TO HAPPEN IN THE FIRST
PLACE WHERE WE SIMPLY JUST NEED
TO INSPECT OUR HOMES. SOME IS
FEELS CATACLYSMIC AND BEYOND
OUR CONTROL THIS PEOPLE BUT THE
FACT IS THE DEMONSTRATE A
COMMUNITY THE BURNS DOWN AND A
COMMUNITY THAT DOESN'T IS OFTEN
A SIMPLE AS GAS GETTING. EVENTS
STEALING YOUR GARAGE AND OTHER
VERY EVERYDAY TASKS FOR
HARDENING YOUR HOME AND
PREVENTING DEFENSIBLE SPACE
FROM BURNING THAT HOUSE DOWN-
THAT TAKES PEOPLE. AND WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE DOING THIS
WORK A DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTION AND HOME HARDENING
SO WITH THIS TRAGEDY OF WHAT OF
FIRE AND CIMATE. WE'VE GOT TO
CONVERT THAT INTO A JOBS
OPPORTUNITY AND THIS BILL IS
ONE SMALL PIECE OF THAT
FRAMEWORK- WE'RE TRYING TO
TRAIN FOLKS IN COMMUNITIES TO
TAKE CONTROL AND PROTECT THEIR
OWN NEIGHBORHOODS TO DO THOSE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTIONS.
TO HELP IDENTIFY HOMES A NEED
TO BE HARDENED NEIGHBOR TO
NEIGHBOR WORK NOT EVEN A THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT KNOCKING ON
YOUR DOOR SOMEONE FROM
GOVERNMENT BUT REAL PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S HIGH TIME
WE ACTUALLY EMPOWER COMMUNITIES.
TO PROTECT OURSELVES NOPE THIS
IS A STEP FORWARD IN A BOTTOM
APPROACH FRANK. TO ATTACK HIS
WILDFIRE RISK AWAY THAT DOESN'T
NEED TO KNOW IN THIS EMPOWER.
OUR YOUR IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK LAST YEAR BUT WAS BROADER
PACKAGE THE- WOULD VETO THE WE
THINK THANKS TO SIMMER FRIEDMAN
SUPPORT. WHO STEPPED UP WHO IS
THE FORMER AUTHOR THAT BILL- WE
CAN DELIVER A WORKFORCE PIECE
TO WILD FIRE THAT'LL ACTUALLY
MAKE PEOPLE SAFER AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
CENTER JACKSON YES VERY
BRIEFLY- THIS- MEASURE
PROVIDES. THE WORK FORCE FOR
PREVENTION. THE GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN VERY- INVOLVED AND
COMMITTED TO FIGHTING FIRES. OF
BUYING EQUIPMENT AND- OF
PUTTING OUT THE FIRES THIS IS A
BILL THAT WAS SENT OUT A WORK
FORCE TO HELP US TRY TO PREVENT
THOSE FIRES. BEFORE THEY HAPPEN
IT IS A CRITICAL TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX. AN OUNCE OF PREVENTION
IS STILL WORTH A POUND OF CURE
AND WITH THAT I WOULD SUPPORT
THE THIS MEASURE AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THE CENTER
JACKSON MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. HEARING
NONE EYES TO NINE KNOWS THE
MEASURE. MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE
PROCEED THERE DOES ANYONE WANT
TO REMOVE ANYTHING FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY FOUR AND SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE WELL I FOR AGES I
BRADFORD. HI I HAVE A ANNA I
CHIANG I DALLY. I DODD I
THEY'RE AWESOME I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TADO. I JACKSON AYE
JONES. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL I MONEY I MORE LOCK
AYE MORRELL. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI AYE WIENER
AYE WILK AYE AYES THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN ADOPTED WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FROM THERE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE. READ SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY
SEVEN AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY EIGHT. VERY
GOOD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. TAKE. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE WELL I FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO I
CHIANG FIVE DOLLY FIVE DODD. I
ASSUME I GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE- TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I MONNING
I MORE LOCK I MORRELL AYE
NIELSEN. I PAN I PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH I RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN I AM BURKE I BY CASKEY
FIVE WIENER. I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SKINNER EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A JOURNEY
MEMORIES SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS- TODAY
IS BOTH A DAY OF CELEBRATION
REMEMBRANCE AND SO I RISE TODAY
TO INTERMEMBRANE OF TWO VERY
IMPORTANT PEOPLE FROM MY
DISTRICT AND I WANT TO ALSO
WELCOME THEIR FAMILIES HERE TO
THE FLOOR. AND IN THE GALLERY
ABOVE- I WENT FIRST START WITH
THE BELOVED LENA FAT VICE
PRESIDENT THE FAT FAMILY
RESTAURANT GROUP. LENA STARTED
HER CAREER AS A PHARMACIST IT
WAS EVENTUALLY A CHOCOLATE CAKE
THAT SHE MADE FOR FAMILY.
TURNED OUT TO BE FOR OUR LESSEN
THE FIASCO. AND THAT MOTIVATED
HER TO LEARN HOW TO COOK. SHE
THEN ATTENDED MANY CULINARY
INSTITUTE AND PRIVATE LESSONS
IN THE UNITED STATES IN HONG
KONG DETERMINED TO EXCEL AS A
SHOT. AND SHE DID. IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR LENA
JOINED THE FAT FAMILY
RESTAURANT GROUP THIS HAD
CORPORATE CHEF WHERE SHE
CREATED A MENU. TO FUSE WESTERN
FOOD WITH CHINESE SPICES AND
TECHNIQUES. UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP ALONG WITH THE REST
OF THE FAT FAMILY THE FAT
RESTAURANT GROUP EXPANDED TO
MORE LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
VENUS CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITY HOWEVER GO BEYOND
JUST HER CULINARY ACHIEVEMENTS.
LENA ALSO LET THE FAT FAMILY TO
PROVIDE GENEROUS PHILANTHROPY
TO THE ARTS THE CHINESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
CHARITABLE EVENTS. HERE THE
SENATE- WE HONOR THE IN THIS WE
WERE HONORED WITH LEAN THIS
PRESENCE WE CELEBRATED FRANK
FATS EIGHTY AT THE END OF OUR-
BACK IN AUGUST LAST YEAR. THE
FIRE HUSBAND THREE CHILDREN AND
EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN. AND SO I
ASK THAT WE- PLEASE JOIN ME
REMEMBERING THE AMAZING LIFE OF
THE IN THE FACT. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
BRING HER NAME FORWARD AND
PROCEED WITH YOUR OTHER ONE AND
THEN I HAVE AN AND ALSO UP ONE
LAST A NOSE IN A PAN. I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR NIELSEN ONE
TO SPEAK ON THIS CENTER
NIELSEN. BETTER PRESIDENT LAYS
DOWN THE SENATE IF I MAY TO.
PIPE IN HERE BECAUSE I'M ONE OF
THE LONG. TENURED PATRONS OF
THAT FINE INSTITUTION. FOR A
LITTLE OVER I BELIEVE HALF OF
THEIR HISTORY I HAVE TRADED AND
ENJOYED THE FAIR THAT FRANK
FACTS. AND KNOWN ALL THE FAMILY
MEMBERS INCLUDING ONE OF THEM
HERE THEY CAN'T. THE
HOSPITALITY AND THE FOOD ARE
ALWAYS THE BEST. ONE THING IS
ALWAYS STUCK IN MY MIND. ABOUT
THAT ORGANIZATION THEY HAVE
OTHER RESTAURANTS. BUT WHAT
NEVER CHANGED. THE LOCATION
HERE UP TO STREET THEY NEVER
GOT AWAY FROM HAVING OUR
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO LEGENDARY
MEETING PLACE OF ALL THE
IMPORTANT BIG DEALS. AND THAT
WAS MEANING TO ME THE HUMILITY
OF THE FAMILY THERE WAS NO BIG
PRETENSE. NEVER HAS BEEN. NOR
HAS THE INSTITUTION EVER.
EVENTS THE ANY OF THAT AT ANY
OF THEIR LOCATIONS AND I'VE
EATEN AT ALL OF THEM OVER THE
YEARS. YOU GO TO FRANK FATS
CORDIAL. WARM AND A WONDERFUL
PLACE TO SEE YOUR FRIENDS.
LINDA IS UCH A LEGEND. AS WAS
WEIGHING FRANK. AND WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE AND I'M VERY HONORED
TO SPEAK IN OUR MEMORY TODAY.
AND I KNOW IT ALL GOOD THINGS
WILL COME CONTINUING TO THE FAT
FAMILY OUR HEARTS AND OUR
PRAYERS ARE WITH YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR PAN AND I ALSO-
BEFORE WE COMPLETE THIS IS
JERMAINE ONE RECOGNIZE THE FAT
FAMILY WHO ARE ISN'T BACK HERE-
THANK YOU I SHOULD ALSO AND
THAT THERE ANY IN THE GALLERY
AS WELL THEIR DAY ARE I SHOULD
ALSO MENTION THAT THEY HAVE-
PROVIDED SOME BANANA CREAM PIE
YOURS COULD COME TO MY OFFICE
AND SAVE MY STAFF- BY HELPING.
ENJOYED SOME OF THE BEEN
EXTREME HIGH I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. IS ALSO WITH A
HEAVY HEART THEY ALSO TURN IN
THE MEMORY OF FIREFIGHTER TO
MERA. TAMMY THATCHER. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS SECTION OF
FIRE DEPARTMENT. FIREFIGHTER
THATCHER PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER SIXTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN. BORN IN CULVER CITY
FIREFIGHTER THATCHER MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR SHE JOINED THE SACRIFICE
DEPARTMENT NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AFTER GRADUATING FROM ELK
GROVE HIGH SCHOOL AND
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
FIREFIGHTERS YOUR SPENT MOST OF
HER ILLUSTRIOUS THIRTY ONE YEAR
CAREER AT STATION FIVE RAISING.
RISING TO THE RANK OF CAPTAIN
SHE SERVED AS A ROLE MODEL
MENTOR FOR MANY ASPIRING FEMALE
FIREFIGHTERS EXEMPLIFYING
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY AND TO
UP AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. I WAS ALWAYS
LOOKING OUT FOR A COLLEAGUES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVING AS A
PEER SUPPORT COUNSELOR IN THE
FIRE DEPARTMENTS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH UNIT FIRE STATURE.
EXITED THE MOST TREASURED HUMAN
QUALITIES UNIVERSALLY
RECOGNIZED AS TWO INDICATORS OF
A FULFILLING AND MEANINGFUL
LIFE. SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER
MOTHER AND STEPFATHER LYNN- AND
MIKE SANDOVAL HER FATHER GEORGE
STATURE HER SISTER NOW HE'S
NATALIE JOHNSON HER NIECE
BAILEY JOHNSON. AND OTHER
EXTENDED SIBLINGS ON UNCLES AND
AUNTS AND WE ARE- HERE JOINED
AND SENATE CHAMBERS BY AGAIN
SUMMER RELATIVES AND THE
MEMBERS OF. THE SECOND A FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND- SACRAMENTO
MAYOR PRO TEM ANGELI GASPEE SO
UP IN THE BACK AND IN THE
GALLERY SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE RETURN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENT HIM
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU BRING BOTH
OF THEIR NAMES FORWARD SO THAT
WE CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
BOTH OF THEM. SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE. I TO
JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF ALL OVER
STORY A LONG TIME SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT. ON DECEMBER SEVENTH
OF TWENTY NINETEEN OLIVER
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY FIVE WITH HIS CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN BY HIS SIDE.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR HE WAS
BORN IN SANTA ROSA TO ITALIAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS AS A HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR OLIVER BECAME A
SOLDIER HE WAS DEPLOYED DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. AND WAS ASSIGNED
TO THE SIXTY SIX BLACK PANTHER
INFANTRY DIVISION. IN NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR OLIVER BRIEFLY
SERVED HIS COUNTRY ON D.DAY.
HE FOUGHT FOR HIS FOR THE
LIBERATION OF WESTERN EUROPE.
FROM THE **** AND- ON THE
SHORES OF NORMANDY. FOLLOWING
THE WAR SETTLE IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE HE MET HIS WIFE LOYOLA
THEY MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE ANDENJOYED FORTY FIVE
HAPPY YEARS TOGETHER. I JOIN
THE SAN FRANCISCO FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. HE BECAME AN ASSISTANT
CHIEFS AND DEVOTED HIS TIME TO
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO UNTIL
HE RETIRED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. AS AN ASSISTANT GP
FACILITATED HIS BURKE GENDER
EQUALITY ACHIEVEMENTS BY HIRING
THE FIRST FIREFIGHTERS D. SAN
FRANCISCO. I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE OLIVER FREE SERVICE
NOT ONLY AS A SOLDIER AND A
VETERAN. BUT ALSO AS A LIFE
LONG PUBLIC SERVANTS HE WAS
DEVOTED TO PROTECTING THE LIVES
OF SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENTS AS A
FIREFIGHTER. OLIVER WAS
PRECEDED IN DEATH AS IF YOU SIR
BY CHILL AND QUIRK WALDRON A
LOT OF A NO ONE OF HIS
DAUGHTERS CELESTE CRIME AND
FROM CV. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY TODAY AND MEMORY OLIVER
STORY. THANKS THERE PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME WE CAN PROBLEM
LIES PLACE FOR THANK YOU MADAM.
MEMBERS OF WITH GREAT. THAT I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
JACK PORTER. JACK WAS A
HISTORIAN- AND A KEEPER OF THE
NATIONAL AIDS MEMORIAL GROVE AT
GOLDEN GATE PARK IN SAN
FRANCISCO. I WAS ALSO ONE OF
THE MOST LOVELY HUMAN BEINGS-
YOU COULD EVER HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF INTERACTING WITH. A
JACK PEACEFULLY PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH. THE AGE OF
EIGHTY ONE. HE GRADUATED IN
BUSINESS AND MARKETING FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF IOWA IN NINETEEN
SIXTY WARY ALSO SANG IN A
CHOIR. AND WAS A SHORT ORDER
COOK. SURELY AFTERWARDS HE
JOINED THE US ARMY SERVING IN
GERMANY AUSTRALIA AND ETHIOPIA.
HE MOVED TO SAN FRANCISCO IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES- LIKE
MANY LGBT PEOPLE DEAD. AND FOR
MANY YEARS HE WORKED FOR THE US
GOVERNMENT AT LOCKHEED MARTIN
IN THE SOUTH BAY. AFTERSHOCKS
RETIREMENT AND HIS PARTNERS ON
UNTIMELY DEATH FROM HIV IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. HE HELPED
TO BRING FRUITION TO HIS
PARTNER'S DREAM TO CREATE THE
AIDS MEMORIAL GROWS AND GOLDEN
GATE PARK. HE WORKED TIRELESSLY
AS A BOARD MEMBER AND SERVED AS
THE UNOFFICIAL MAYOR OF THE
GROVE. WHERE HE CONTINUALLY
WORKED AND GAVE OF HIMSELF FOR
OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS. JACK
WAS AN ADVOCATE FOR LGBTQ
RIGHTS HE SERVED ON PUBLIC. OF
HIS INNER. JACK'S LAW IS A
TRAGEDY FOR HIS FAMILY FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND FOR THE AIDS
MEMORIAL GROWS HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS STEP CHILDREN AND HIS
SISTER JILL BY COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A DURING THE
SAUNA AND MEMORY OF JACK PORTER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
WITH A PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD ALSO SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. THIRTY
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF A
TALENTED CARING AND
COMPASSIONATE CALIFORNIANS THAT
IN THE NAME OF ANDREW LOVELL
PRICES SECOND. AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS MOVIE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. HE WAS A SON A
BROTHER AND A FATHER OF THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN. HE WAS THE ONLY
CHILD OF DTE AND ANDREW PRICE'S
MOTHER SPENT THIRTY PLUS YEARS
WITH LAPD. AND IF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE NAME ANDREW
PRICE BETTER KNOWN AS THE HAWK
HE FOUGHT A WAS- TO A WORLD
CLASS WELTERWEIGHT FIGHTER WHO
FOUGHT SUGAR RAY LEONARD.
ANDREW WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES
AND GREW UP IN THISCITY OF
GARDENA JUST RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER FROM ME I'VE KNOWN HIM
SINCE HE WAS THREE YEARS OLD.
WORRIES KNOWN AS A HIP HOP
ARTISTS ALSO KNOWN AS Y. G.
SOPRANO. HE GRADUATED FROM
SAINT BERNARD'S CATHOLIC HIGH
SCHOOL AND WENT ON TO ATTEND EL
CAMINO COLLEGE WHERE HE PURSUED
HIS CAREER AND BOTH MUSIC AND
DANCE. AND EXPERIENCED
COMMERCIAL SUCCESS WITH THE RAP
GROUP. THE BILL COULD ENJOY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY WITH A VARIETY OF
ARTISTS. IN ADDITION TO HIS
MUSIC CAREER AND YOU WORK FOR
YEARS WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES LIKE HIS FATHER
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION- AS ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR AND WAS RE A RENOWNED.
BASEBALL COACH FOR HUNDREDS OF
YOUNG KIDS. HE WAS A MAN OF
TREMENDOUS FAITH WHO CHERISH
HIS ROLE AS A FATHER OF HIS
CHILDREN AND YOUR THIRD. YOUR
RIGHTS- WHY YOU AND DREW. HE
TOOK GREAT JOY IN COACHING BOTH
BASEBALL AND BASKETBALL
ATTENDING SPORTING EVENTS
BOXING EVENTS WITH HIS FATHER
PERSONAL FRIENDS WITH SUGAR RAY
LEONARD COOKING- FOR HIS FAMILY
WAS ALSO KNOWN AS SIR SAUCY
BECAUSE OF HIS GREAT COOKING
TALENTS AND HIS LIFE WAS CUT
FAR TOO SHORT. AT THE YOUNG AGE
OF THIRTY SIX BUT HIS LEGACY
WILL LIVE ON THROUGH HIS MUSIC
HIS COACHING AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A JOURNEY IN IN THE MEMORY
OF ANDREW FELL PRICE. SECOND HE
SAID BRADFORD IS BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO IT MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT NEVER SEE I RISE
TESTED WE TURNED IN MEMORY OF
FORMER UNITED STATES
CONGRESSMAN- FORTNEY PETE STARK
JUNIOR WHO PASSED AWAY AT HIS
HOME. A LAST FRIDAY AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE WAS A
GIANT OF EAST BAY POLITICS AND
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM
FOR FORTY YEARS FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE. TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN HE WAS AN INFLUENTIAL
FIGURE IN AMERICAN HEALTHCARE
POLICY- BUT IT WAS A PRIVATE
SECTOR WE REALLY MADE HIS FIRST
MARK. A WISCONSIN NATIVE HE GOT
AN ENGINEERING DEGREE FROM MIT
THEN HE WENT WEST TO CAL AND
GOT AN MBA. FORCE HERE FOR THEN
IT STARTED HIS OWN BANK
SECURITY NATIONAL. AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT AT CAL ON THE CORNER
BANCROFT I TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THE FREE CHECKING ACCOUNTS THAT
HE OFFERED ANY AS WELL AS FREE
CHILDCARE FOR ALL THE
EMPLOYEES. HE WAS KNOWN AS A
RACIAL AND GENDER EQUITY
MEASURES THAT HE- HEALTH TO
ALWAYS EMPLOYEES WHO. AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE VIETNAM WAR HE
RICK TO THE GIANT PEACE SIGN ON
THE SIDE OF THE BANK'S
HEADQUARTERS IN WALNUT CREEK IF
YOU GO DOWN. INTERSTATE SIXTY
EIGHTY AS A PROTEST SYMBOL BY
THE TIME HE WAS ELECTED TO
CONGRESS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO SECURITY NATIONAL HAVE
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
IN CALIFORNIA. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE HE BECAME THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE POWERFUL WAYS
AND MEANS COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH HIS
SIGNATURE LEGISLATIVE
ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS CREATING
WHAT WE KNOW NOW IS THE COBRA A
PROGRAM. ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS
TO CONTINUE THEIR HEALTHCARE
INSURANCE EVEN AFTER LOSING
THEIR JOBS AND PREVENTING TENS
OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS FROM
EXPERIENCING THE EIGHT
INTERRUPTIONS FROM THEIR
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. HE PASSED
LEGISLATION PREVENTING
HOSPITALS FROM TURNING ANYONE
SEEKING EMERGENCY TREATMENT
AWAY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO PLAY. HIT MADE LIFE
SAVING EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE A
RIGHT RATHER THAN A PRIVILEGE
IN THE UNITED STATES. LEVERAGE
HIS ROLE IS THE CHAIR OF THE
HEALTH SUBCOMMITTEE TO SHIELD
MEDI CAL INSULTS THE SECURITY
FROM ATTACKS BY THOSE WHO
SOUGHT TO WEAKEN IT OR TO
PRIVATIZE THE CYST. ANYWAY ALSO
A KEY PROTECT THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT. HE WAS THE PERSON IN
ADVOCATE FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AN OPPONENT OF THE
IRAQ WAR AND A STRONG
ENVIRONMENTS HE WAS WHITE
CONGRESSMAN. FOR THOSE WORK
WITH HIM BILL DORMAN PETE A MAN
WITH WITH AND A GOOD SENSE OF
HUMOR ABOVE ALL THEY REMEMBER
HIM AS A MAN OF COURAGE WHO
NEVER HESITATED TO PICK A
WORTHY FIGHT AGAINST THE
POWERFUL ON BEHALF OF THE
UNDERSERVED. FORMER CONGRESSMAN
STARK IS SURVIVED BY HIS SECOND
WIFE OF TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
DEBORAH RODRICK STARK HIT SEVEN
CHILDREN AND THEIR SPOUSES A
GRAND KIDS IN TWO GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN. ADAM THAT WE TURN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HE PLEASE BEING BRING HIS
NAME PORTS SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE ONE MORE RICHARD
A MEMORY THAT WILL BE DONE BY
TWO SENATORS CENTER MARK ARE
YOU BEGINNING. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- WORK
TO START. KOBE BRYANT WAS IN A
MAY. SIGNET FIGURE IN THE-
UNITED STATES. OBVIOUSLY
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS SIGNIFICANT
IN THE LIVES OF MY CHILDREN. SO
THE FIRST TEXT MESSAGES I GOT
YESTERDAY WERE FROM THEM. MY
OLDEST BOY PLAYED VARSITY
BASKETBALL. IN HIGH SCHOOL BUT
TODAY'S NEWSPAPERS FOR THE- IF
I MAY DISPLAYS SOME OF THE
MADAM PRESIDENT BUT JUST THE
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SURPRISE
SPENT THE ENTIRE SPORTS PAGE OF
THE REGISTER THE- THE ENTIRE
FRONT PAGE OF. THE REGISTER
THAT. LOS ANGELES TIMES ARADIA
TRIBUTE TODAY- THAT IS WORTH
READING AND ALSO MAKING IT TO
THE FRONT PAGE OF. TODAY'S LA
TIMES WERE CALIFORNIA LOST A
GIANT YESTERDAYMORNING AND
IT'S STILL VERY FRESH. THE
HELICOPTER WAS REPORTEDLY ON
ITS WAY FROM JOHN WAYNE AIRPORT
OF ORANGE COUNTY THE THOUSAND
OAKS. WHERE BRENT WAS SCHEDULED
TO COACH A TOURNAMENT GAME AT
MOMBASA SPORTS ACADEMY IT
TRAGICALLY CRASHED IN CALABASAS
JUST A FEW MILES FROM THEIR
DESTINATION. IN A FOGGY MORNING
TAKING THE LIVES OF NINE PEOPLE
FIVE OF WHICH WERE CONSTITUENTS
OF MINE INCLUDING KOBE BRYANT.
I DON'T NEED TO GO THROUGH THE
MANY RECORDS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS- THEY ARE MANY
BUT- HE WAS AN ICON OF
BASKETBALL IT WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR THE LEGACY HE
LEFT IN SPORTS. AMONG HIS
PHILANTHROPIC ENDEAVORS THE
BASKETBALL GREAT HAS PARTNERED
WITH THE NONPROFIT AFTER SCHOOL
ALL STARS AS PART OF THE KOBE
AND VANESSA BRYANT. FAMILY
FOUNDATION HE ALSO RUNS AN
ANNUAL SUMMER CAMP CALLED THE
KOBE BASKETBALL ACADEMY. HE
FOCUSED ON GIRLS IN SPORTS AND
HIS SECOND CAREER OF CHILDREN'S
BOOKS AND HAD HIS STUDIO IN HAS
A STUDIO IN COSTA MESA. HE DIED
PASSING THE TRADITION. AND HIS
LOVE OF SPORTS WITH HIS
DAUGHTER AND OTHER YOUNG
ASPIRING BASKETBALL PLAYERS ALL
WHO CALLED HIM A FRIEND. THIS
ALL HAPPENED JUST TWO WEEKS OUT
FROM THE I'M A SPORTS ACADEMIES
IN ARBOR WOMEN'S PERFORMANCE
SUMMIT. WHEN ASKED WHAT IS A
HALLMARK MOM BUT MENTALITY WAS
HE STATED SIMPLY MAMA MENTALITY
IS IN ABOUT SEEKING RESULT IT'S
ABOUT BERNIE. THE WAY OF WHAT.
MEANS ABLE AWESOME THE BE THE
FIRST OF YOUR CELL. MY WIFE AND
I HAVE ONLY MET. KOBE IN.
FINESSE ONCE SAID IN EVENT
PRETTY CITY IN IRVINE- BUT
FRIENDS OF MINE DID BUY THEIR
HOME SO I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
HOME BUT- HIS FORMER HOME. BUT
HE WAS VERY ACTIVE IN MY AREA
OF COSTA MESA WERE MY DISTRICT
OFFICE IS LOCATED IN ONE OF MY
CLOSE FRIENDS HE AND HIS WIFE
AND- FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
JIM RIG HAMMER AND HIS WIFE.
GIVE ME A LOT LANE OF SKEWS ME.
WERE VERY CLOSE IT AND CUT WE
WOULD VISIT JUST JUST A FEW
HOUSES FROM MY HOME. AND SO I
CALLED JIM THIS MORNING JUST A
WHAT WHAT KIND OF COMMENTS
WOULD YOU HAVE AN AND HE JUST
COULDN'T TALK HE WAS STILL. SO.
EMOTIONAL ABOUT THE LOSS OF A
FRIEND. WE ALSO LOST A VERY
RESPECTED BASEBALL COACH JOHN
ALL TO BELLY- HE WAS LONG TIME
COACH- FOR ORANGE COAST COLLEGE
WHICH IS ALSO MY DISTRICT IN
JUST A COUPLE BLOCKS FROM MY
HOME. ALONG WITH HIS WIFE KERRY
AND THEIR DAUGHTER LISA. ALL TO
BELLY LED HIS TEAM TO FOR STATE
CHAMPIONSHIPS DURING HIS CAREER
AND WAS NAMED THE NATIONAL
COACH OF THE YEAR. BY THE
AMERICAN BASEBALL COACHES
ASSOCIATION AND TWENTY NINETEEN
IS NOTED FOR HIS LOVE OF HIS
PLAYERS AND OFTEN TREATING THEM
LIKE FAMILY. I COULD GO ON BUT
I KNOW THERE ARE OTHERS THAT
WANT TO SPEAK SOME MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO A
GERMAN IN THE MEMORY OF KOBE
BRYANT JUST FORTY ONE FROM
NEWPORT COAST. HIS LEVY
DAUGHTER G. ON A BRAND
THIRTEEN. JOHN ALTOBELLI FATHER
AND WELL RESPECTED OCC BASEBALL
COACH AND- IN CONSTITUENTS CARE
HIS WIFE KERRY THE DAUGHTER
LISA. ALSO WHEN I. REMEMBER
SERRA CHESTER A MOTHER AND HER
DAUGHTER. IN CHESTER AND
CRISTINA MAUSER AND MAMBA
BASKETBALL COACH AND THEN THE
PILOT. ARE A SO BEYOND- MAY WE
NEVER FORGET THESE LOS FATHERS
MOTHERS DAUGHTERS. AND BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AND CONTINUE TO BE
THE BEST VERSION OF OURSELVES
AND OUR LOVE IN MEMORY THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER MORLOCK CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
JUST WANT TO LEND MY VOICE IN
THIS TO GERMAN- NOT ONLY KOBE
BRYANT BUT THE OTHER EIGHT
VICTIMS OF THIS TRAGIC LOSS.
YESTERDAY AND I TOLD COLBY WAS
NOT A CONSTITUENT OF MINE PER
SE. HE STARTED OFFICE BASKET
BALL CAREER IN MY DISTRICT AT
THE FABULOUS FORM. AND IT WAS
THERE THAT I MET HIM FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME I BELIEVE IT
WAS A SECOND YEAR. WITH THE
LAKERS AND IF YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE FORM. IT WAS THE FORM
CLUB THAT YOU WANT TO BE SEEING
OR BE SEEING SEE AND I'M CLUB
EITHER. BEFORE THE GAME AT
HALFTIME OR AFTER THE GAME
BECAUSE YOU KNEW ATHLETES AND
CELEBRITIES WOULD COME INTO THE
FORM CLUB. BUT CALL WASN'T OLD
ENOUGH TO GO IN THE FORM CLUB.
AND I HAPPEN TO BE AT THE GAME
THAT NIGHT ONE NIGHT AND I AM
WITH A FRIEND OF MINE WHO HAS A
YOUNG SON AND CROSSED THE HALL
THEY HAD ANOTHER ROOM. FOR
pTHEY ALWAYS HAD A BIG- AMAZING
SPREAD OF FOOD AND PRETZELS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO WE
WALKED IN THERE THAT NIGHT
AFTER THE GAME THE HANG OUT
WITH MY FRIENDS SON AND- WHO
WALKS IN. KOBE BRYANT. AND HE
WAS THE MOST HUMBLE INDIVIDUAL
BECAUSE- I HAD ALREADY MADE UP
MY MIND I'M LIKE. THIS YOUNG
SUPERSTAR HE'S GONNA BE HERE
AGAIN HE'S GOING TO BE THIS IS
GOING TO BE THAT. LIKE MOST
ATHLETES YOU FAR FROM THE
TRUTH. THE LOOK IN YOUR EYE HE
SHOOK YOUR HAND AND- HE ENGAGE
YOU AN- INTELLIGENT.
CONVERSATION AND IT WAS ONE OF
GREAT CONFIDENCE AS WE HAVE
SEEN THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS SECURE. AND
WE WAS A INDIVIDUAL WHO DID NOT
SPEND A DAY IN COLLEGE BUT WAS
FLUENT IN THREE LANGUAGES. I
INDIVIDUAL WHO DIDN'T SPEND A
DAY IN COLLEGE BUT WAS FAR MORE
TO KILL IT THEN FOLKS I'VE
KNOWN WHO'VE MATRICULATED TO.
ADVANCED DEGREES IN COLLEGE BUT
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS
WORRIEDLY AS PRESENCE AND
MATURE BEYOND ALL A BEYOND HIS
AGE. AND JUST ONE OF THE MOST
HUMBLE HUMAN BEINGS THAT YOU
COULD HAVE EVER IMAGINED
BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW WE ALL
KNOW ATHLETE. AND THE PLAY ON
THE PROFESSIONAL OUT LEVEL
THEY'RE ALL TALENTED. BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT SEPARATES THE
TALENT FROM THE GREAT ONES AND
HE WAS ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO
PUT IN THE WORK HE HAD A GREAT
WORK ETHIC. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY HE WAS DETERMINED
HE WAS CONFIDENT AND IT WAS A
EIGHTEEN MAY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY HE WAS A GREAT
FATHER. HE WAS A GREAT SONG ON
HE WAS A GREAT HAPPEN AT ANY IS
GREAT HUMAN BEING THANK. ALL
SHOULD. NO BETTER CALL BRYANT.
AWAY AT TRY TO EMULATE THAT
SOME TO AND ARE BUT LET NOT
FORGET JOHN DOE AND THE OTHERS
WHO LAW HER LIFE TRAGIC LOST
STE THE YESTERDAY SO I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN ALL NINE
OTHER MEMBERS. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE ALL OF A-
WELL A PERSONAL STORY
ESPECIALLY LAWS AND BUT
CERTAINLY ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT WHAT. KOBE
MEANT TO US UNIFIED TO. KIND OF
CITY THAT JUST REFUSED TO BE
UNIFIED SOMETIMES ALMOST TOO
BIG TO. BE FOR ANY ONE THING-
BUT SOMEHOW HE PUT THAT
FRANCHISE IN A PLACE THAT-
BROUGHT EVERYONE REACHING FOR
ALL WALKS LIFE TOGETHER- AND
TAUGHT US ABOUT FEROCITY- BUT I
ALSO I JUST WANT TAKE MY BRIEF
MOMENT TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. TO
TALK ABOUT NOT NOT JUST JANA
BUT THE OTHER MEMBERS THAT
HELICOPTER YOU KNOW IT TO BE
ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS PEOPLE
IN THE GRACE BASS WILL PLAYERS
OF ALL TIME. I FRANKLY THINK
THEY SHOULD MAKE THE LOGO-
JERRY WEST FOUND EVEN MAYBE
IT'S- YEAH FOR THE YEAR AND PUT
COULD BE UP THERE. BUT I JUST
WANT TO CALL OUT THE OTHER
PASSENGERS ON THAT FLIGHT BY
NAME AND I GOTTA TELL YOU.
GOING HOME THIS WEEKEND ABOUT
AN HOUR AFTER THE CRASH YOU IS.
THE AREA'S FEELING. THERE IS
THIS BEAUTIFUL MORNING AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT EVEN
HAPPENED IN THE MIST IS OUT
THERE AND THE BIRDS ARE
CHIRPING IT'S LIKE THE
MOUNTAINS DIDN'T EVEN KNOW.
WHAT IT HAPPENED TWO THOUSAND
YARDS AWAY FROM ME THAT
VIOLENCE IT JUST GOT SWALLOWED
UP BUT I KNOW THE MEMORIES WILL
GO ON. SO ALSO I FULLY KNOWN AS
JOHN ON THE BELLY. AND HIS WIFE
CARRYING HIS DAUGHTER LISTA
COURSE AN AMAZING COACH IN AN
AMAZING FAMILY BUT THAT DAY HE
WAS BEING A GREAT DAD HE WAS
FOLLOWING HIS DAUGHTER OFF TO
HER GAME- SIR HITCHED A RIDE.
THE MOM INSTITUTED OPEN UP IN
NEWBURY PARK AND SHE WAS A
TEAMMATE SO YOU PUT ASIDE HIS
HIS DUTIES IN. AND STEPPED UP
THAT DATA TO GO ROUTE ON FOR
HIS DAUGHTER LISTS. TO HIS WIFE
CARRIE. SO THEY WERE LOST. AND
SERIN PAYING CHESTER WHO WERE
MOTHER AND A DAUGHTER GREW UP.
LIKE SO MANY KIDS DO- PLAYING
SPORTS ROOM FOR TEAMS- BUT GROW
UP IN PLACE A CORONA DEL MAR
YOU THINK LIFE JUST PERFECT AND
NOTHING CAN EVER TOUCH YOU
UNFORTUNATELY. CENTER AND
PAYING GOT TOUCHED. HI ANDY
GEORGIA BROTHERS THERE IS.
MENTION THAT. SHE THE SWEETEST
SOUL THE KINDEST MOST GENTLE S.
PERSON YOU'D EVER MEET SHOWS
HAD A HUGE SMILE ON HER FACE
AND EVERY TIME WE WOULD SEE
YOUR SHE WOULD SPEND ALL OUR
TIME WITH. MY OLD DAUGHTERS I
ALSO WANT TO. FOCUS FOR A
MOMENT CRISTINA MAUSER. ALSO
KNOWN AS THE MOTHER OF DEFENSE.
HI MOM INSTITUTE WAS BECOMING
VERY SPECIALS A PLACE TO TRAIN
FEROCIOUS YOUNG WOMEN. TO BE
GREAT ATHLETE. N. JOHN ALSO
KNOWS GIGI YOU REALLY THE
EPICENTER THAT BUT CRISTINA
MAUSER WAS DESIGNED TO BE THE
ARCHITECT- TO BRING THAT. THE
MOB MENTALITY THE COURT FOR
YOUNG WOMEN WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TOLD TO SIT ON THE SIDELINES OR
WAIT THEIR TURN- PLAYABLE
SOFTER- SHE SHE ENCOURAGED HER
HER TEAMMATES AND HER HER
STUDENTS TO PLAY HARD ARE MADE
IN A LOT FOR. APP AFTER AFTER
GAMES AND GO THROUGH TAPE IN
THIS WITH SIX AND SEVENTH
GRADERS. SO WILL DEARLY MISS
CHRISTINA MAUSERS WELL AND
FINALLY HOURS ABOUT A ARE AS A
BY. HE'S FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH
AND A COMMERCIAL HELICOPTER
PILOT AND CERTIFIED FLIGHT
INSTRUCTOR THE PHONE FOR TWENTY
YEARS. AND HIS BEST FRIENDS ARE
ONE OF HIS BEST FRIENDS JARED
YO CAME SAID HE WAS NOT A
TYPICAL EGOTISTICAL HELICOPTER
PILOT LIKE MOST OF US. HE WAS A
MAN THAT ALWAYS REMAIN COOL
CALM AND COLLECTED. ENDS HERE
IN THIS MOMENT AS WE ALL MOURN
IS A CITY IN THE STATE FOR THE
LOSS OF A GIANT I JUST THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. TO NOTE THAT.
SMALL PEOPLE PEOPLE THAT WILL
NEVER KNOW- GET LOST IN THESE
TRAGEDIES TOO SO I RISE TO
GERMAN ALL THEIR MEMORIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I CERTAINLY ARE.
RIGHTS ARE IN MOURNING FOR
THOSE NINE VICTIMS OF THAT
HORRIBLE CRASH UNFORTUNATELY TO
OUR RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT-
LIVED IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
SERRA CHESTER AND HER THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER PEYTON. ARE
THEY WERE TWO OF THE NINE
VICTIMS WHO WERE INVOLVED
YESTERDAY MORNING PEYTON WAS AN
EIGHTH GRADE STUDENT AT ST
MARGARET'S EPISCOPAL SCHOOL IN
MY DISTRICT WHERE HER MOTHER
SARAH SERVED ON. TRUSTEES THERE
IS THERE AND THE GEORGE SAID.
WAS ON THAT AIR AND CAN. SHE
WAS THERE TO HER FOR TO OUR
FOR. ANY I NEEDED ANYTHING SHE
WAS THE PERSON I WENT TO. SHE
IS STRONG KIND INTELLIGENT
FUNNY AND WAS EVERYTHING TO US
PEYTON I WAS THE GENTLEST
PERSON YOU WOULD EVER MEET SHE
WAS ON MAMBA. BASKETBALL TEAM
FOR YEARS ALONG WITH KIANA
BRYANT KOBE BRYANT'S DAUGHTER
AND SHE PLANNED ON PLAYING
BASKETBALL IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEN AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL.
SERRA AND SERRA AND PEYTON
CHESTER ARE SURVIVED
RESPECTIVELY BY HUSBAND AND
FATHER CHRIS AND SONS AND
BROTHERS HAYDEN AND RILEY WHO
ARE BOTH ONLY JUST IN THE TENTH
GRADE. SERIN PEYTON OR BOTH
GENUINE KIND HEARTED AND CARING
PEOPLE THE FORMER PRINCIPAL OF
A ROOF HARBOR VIEW ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TODD SCHMIDT TO NEW
PATIENT AS ONE OF HIS STUDENTS.
AND SERRA AS A PARENT PAID THEM
THIS BUTTE. YOU WERE BOTH
EMBODY MANTA OF HASH TAG HAVE
PRIDE. AND THE WORLD IS JUST A
LITTLE LESS WITHOUT YOU BOTH IN
IT. MAY YOU BOTH REST IN PEACE
AND KNOW THE DEEP IMPACT YOU
HAD ON OUR LIVES YOU WILL BE
SORELY MISSED SO I A JAIL I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN. SERRA
AND PEYTON CHESTER'S MEMORY
ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER
VICTIMS OF THE SMALL DURABLE.
THANK YOU. IT'S CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MADAM
PRESIDENT I NOT ONLY STAND AS A
LIFE LONG LAKER GIRLS BUT I
PROUDLY REPRESENT THE HOUSE
THAT THE BLACK MAMBA BUILT
STAPLE CENTER IS IN THE THIRTY
SENATE DISTRICT. AND I SHEER BY
DEEP THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS AND
CONDOLENCES AS MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE EXPRESSED WITH
ALL OF THE FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
AND LOVED ONES WHO WERE TOUCHED
BY YESTERDAY'S TRAGIC ACCIDENT.
THE MOM BUT I'M GOING TO CHOOSE
TO SPEND MY TIME. TO TALK ABOUT
KOBE BRYANT. BECAUSE AT THIS
TIME IN OUR COUNTRY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. POLITICALLY
SOCIALLY ECONOMICALLY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE. BUT WHILE HIS
ATHLETIC ACCU MEN WAS INDEED
EXCEPTIONAL. COLBY THE MAN WAS
NOT. BECAUSE HE DID WHAT IS AND
WAS EXPECTED. HE DEAR WHAT
COUNTLESS OTHER BLACK MEN
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY DO EVERY
DAY. HE WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT
JUSTICE HE SUPPORTED THE
EXPANSION OF ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE. HE WAS A GENEROUS
PHILANTHROPISTS. HE WAS A
DEVOTED FATHER. A FATHER LIKE
MANY OTHER FATHERS WHO GAVE HIS
BABY NICKNAMES THE MAMBA CETUS.
A FATHER WHO COACHED HIS BABY'S
BASKETBALL TEAM. WE WATCHED HIM
GROW UP LITERALLY AT FEET INTO
THE NBA AT SEVENTEEN IN THE
PUBLIC EYE NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY EASY TO DO. AND WE WATCHED
HIM MATURE WE WTCH THAT BABY
FACE TURNED IN- FELT LIKE
OVERNIGHT TO ME INTO THIS HIS
OLD BEAUTIFUL GROWN MAN. WE
WATCH TO BE INVOLVED IN BLOSSOM
INTO A TEAM LEADER. A POET AN
OSCAR LEE AND OSCAR WINNER.
BEFORE I CLOSE I'D LIKE TO READ
AN EXCERPT FROM KOBE'S POEM
DEAR BASKETBALL. THAT'S THE
POINT THAT LED TO THE ANIMATED
SHORT THAT WON HIM THAT OSCAR
LAST YEAR. YOU GAVE THE SIX
YEAR OLD BOY HIS LAKER DREAM.
AND I'LL ALWAYS LOVE YOU FOR
IT. BUT I CAN'T LOVE YOU
OBSESSIVELY MUCH LONGER. THE
SEASON IS ALL I HAVE LEFT TO
GIVE. MY HEART CAN TAKE THE
POUNDING MY MIND CAN HANDLE THE
GRIND BUT BY MY BUT Y BODY
KNOWS IT'S TIME TO SAY GOODBYE.
HE WAS MORE THAN AN EXCEPTIONAL
ATHLETE. COLBY IS AN WAS A
CULTURAL ICON AND THE MEMORY OF
OUR BLACK MAMBAS PASSION
DEDICATION. SHARE DRIVE AND
COMMITMENT AND LOVE FOR HIS
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. CONTINUE
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME. I
ASKED THE OUIJA EARNED IN HIS
LIVING MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY ON THE SOLEMN
OCCASION TO DOING MY COLLEAGUES
IN REMEMBERING THOSE WHO WERE
LOST IN SUNDAY'S HELICOPTER
CRASH IN CALABASAS. MY FAMILY
IN OUR OUR LIFETIME OF FANS OF
LAKERS BUT NOT. LIKE MY BROTHER
AND AT HIS LEVEL HE NAMED. HIS
SON MY NEPHEW AFTER KOBE BRYANT
SO- HIS NAME IS KOBE CHIANG.
AND HE WILL BE FOREVER
MEMORIALIZED IN MY FAMILY.
APART FROM LOSS OF. LA LAKERS
LEGEND KOBE BRYANT AND HIS
DAUGHTERS JANA THE ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITIES ALSO ROCK BY
THE LOSS OF COACH JON ALTER
BELLY HIS WIFE CARRIE AND THEIR
JON CARIN WAS CELTIC VALUE
RESONATES DEEP WITHIN THE
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY AND
THOSE WHO LOVE THEM IN NEW THEM
BASS. MANY RESIDENTS IN MY
DISTRICT AND THE NEIGHBORING
DISTRICT OF CENTER MORLOCKS CAN
COUNT THEMSELVES AMONG THOSE
WHO BENEFITTED UNDER COACH ALL
TO BILLS AWARD WINNING
LEADERSHIP. AND GUIDANCE ON AND
OFF THE FIELD SO PLEASE JOIN ME
IN EXTEND YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS TO ALL NINE OF THE
VICTIM'S FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG THIRD
RAZA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. WE
ARE SUFFERING A VERY SHOCKING
AND HEART WRENCHING LOSS. I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES BUT HE
WAS MUCH MUCH MARCH MORE. THEN
THE ATHLETE THE GREAT ATHLETES
BUT FOR THE RECORD. FIVE TIME
NBA WORLD CHAMPION. EIGHTEEN
TIME NBA ALL STAR. HIS ENTIRE
TWENTY YEAR NBA CAREER WAS WITH
THE LOS ANGELES LAKERS. IN ALL
OF HIS THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BECAUSE OF ALL OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS TO JERSEYS WERE
RETIRED IN HIS NAME. ANY
REACHED AN EIGHTY ONE POINT
GAME. YES COLBY MEANT SO MUCH
MORE THAN HIS ACCOLADES AND
STATISTICS. HIS TALENT AND HIS
COMMITMENT TO HIS CRAFT MADE
THE WORD COLBY SYNONYMOUS WITH
GREATNESS. HE INSPIRED A
GENERATION OF BOYS AND GIRLS
NOT ONLY TO COMPETE AND
ATHLETICS BUT ALSO TO STRIVE
WITH ALL OF YOUR EFFORT IN
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE TO
IMPROVE TO SUCCEED. AND
STARTING WITH HIS OWN FAMILY.
YOU'VE ALL HEARD AND READ ABOUT
THE STORIES OF HIS DAUGHTER
GIGI. THERE WAS A STORY THAT I
READ ABOUT SOMEONE COMING UP TO
COLBY I THINK IT WAS WHEN HE
WAS RETIRING AND SAID. YOU
GOTTA HAVE A SON KERRY ON YOUR
LEGACY AND HIS DAUGHTER WAS
STANDING RIGHT THERE AND HE
LOOKED BETTER AND SHE SAID I
GOT A DAD. SHE WAS GOING TO
CARRY ON THAT LEGACY. CODE B.
SPIRIT LIVES ON EVERY TIME WE
SEE THE NUMBERS EIGHT AND
TWENTY FOUR HANGING IN THE
RAFTERS OF STAPLES CENTER IN
EVERY TIME A CHILD YELLS COLBY.
WHEN ATTEMPTING A SHOT WHETHER
THEY'RE USING A BASKETBALL OR
ROLLED UP SOCK. HE WAS NOT
PERFECT NO HUMAN BEING IS BUT
HE TAUGHT US NEVER TO GIVE UP
HE SHOWED US THAT WITH
DEDICATION AND DISCIPLINE ONE
COULD ALWAYS BECOME. AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID A BETTER VERSION
OF WHAT THEY ARE. THE WORLD
WILL FEEL THE PAIN OF THEIR
LOSS FOR SOME TIME. ONLY FOUR
YEARS SINCE KOBE'S RETIREMENT
HE AND HIS DAUGHTER HAD ONLY
JUST STARTED. THIS NEXT CHAPTER
OF THEIR LIVES. HE WAS A ROLE
MODEL ON MANY LEVELS. HE DID
THINGS NOT TO BE POLITICALLY
CORRECT HE JUST DID THINGS
BECAUSE HE WAS A DECENT HUMAN
BEING. TO HELP AND LOVE OTHERS
WITH NO DISTINCTION. SPOKE
ITALIAN VERY PROUDLY TO LEARN
SPANISH. WHICH ENDEARED HIM TO
THE LATINO COMMUNITY AND HE WAS
PROUD TO TALK ABOUT BEING
MARRIED TO A MEXICAN WOMAN AND
THAT HIS CHILDREN WERE MEXICAN.
AND I UNDERSTAND HE WAS
BEGINNING TO LEARN TO SPEAK
MANDARIN. I MET HIM WHEN I WAS
A MEMBER OF THE UNITED WAY
BOARD OF DIRECTORS HE AGREED TO
BE THE SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
HALLMARK. TO BRING
CONSCIOUSNESS TO THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS MIND YOU THAT WAS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. WHEN IT HAD
NOT GOTTEN AS BAD AS IT IS
TODAY WHEN YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT IT HE PERSONALLY GOT
INVOLVED BECAUSE OF HIS DEEP
CONCERN FOR HUMANITY. HE
PERSONALLY WAS AT ALL OF THE
KICK OFF FOR THE WHOLE MARK. HE
DONATED TO THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
SMITHSONIAN HE CARED A LOT
ABOUT KIDS WITH THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUBS AND OTHER YOUTH
PROGRAMS HE READ TO KIDS TO THE
COMMUNITY COALITION PROGRAMS.
HE HAS BEEN A HERO TO MY SON
MICHAEL HIS WHOLE LIFE. MICHAEL
IS AN ADMIRERS NOT ONLY BECAUSE
OF HIS EXTRAORDINARY SKILLS.
AND TO BE PROUD TO SAY WAS A
LAKER. BECAUSE YOUR- COLBY WAS
SO DETERMINED THAT'S WHY
MICHAEL WOULD SAY AND SAID TO
ME HE WANTED TO GROW UP AND BE
LIKE KOBE. MAY HE REST IN PEACE
ALONGSIDE HIS DAUGHTER AND
FRIENDS WHO DIED WITH HIM. MAY
GOD STRENGTHEN HIS WIFE AND
DAUGHTERS AND ALL THE FAMILIES
WHO LOST A LOVED ONE DURING
WHAT WILL SURELY BE A VERY
PAINFUL TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO FOR ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO SPOKE PLEASE MAKE
SURE WE GET THE NAMES OF ALL
THE VICTIM SO THAT WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED ALL OF
THEM. THANK YOU MEMBERS MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS I THINK SENATOR
STERN YOU HAD AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
THE. SHORT SENATOR RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEES ACTUALLY
TO A JOINT HEARING WITH
ASSEMBLY NATURI SEARCHES THAT I
BELIEVE IS ALREADY UNDER WAY-
SO THEY THEY WE GAME LEAD TO
GET STARTED WITHOUT US BUT
WE'RE COMPETING IMMEDIATELY
UPON A TERM. VERY GOOD. GOOD
QUESTION. I DON'T KNOW. THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU GIVE ME
THE MICROPHONE IT'S A FOUR IN
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. ALL AGES
MATTER PRESENT FOR THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU CENTER STERN- CENTER
GLAZER I THINK YOU HAVE AN
OUNCE ONE AS WELL. LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE CONDITION OF THE
FILE. OKAY IT'S ANNOUNCEMENT
IT'S NOT TECHNICALLY A
CONDITION OF THE FILE SO GO
AHEAD. YOU CAN MAKE YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT- MEMBERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS EARLIER
TODAY- THE A RULES COMMITTEE
ASKS THAT SB FIFTY BE MOVED
FROM THAT COMMITTEE TO THE
FLOOR. AT THAT IS NOT AN
UNCOMMON EVENT THAT WE- HERE
FROM TAT COMMITTEE THEY'RE IN
CHARGE OF MANAGING THE FLOW OF
LEGISLATION. BUT WHEN THE
MATTER COMES THE FLOOR TO
PROCEDURAL MATTER. AND
ACCORDINGLY I VOTED IN FAVOR OF
THAT REQUEST. IT'S NOT A VOTE
ON THE SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL TO
VOTE ON THE PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED IN HOUSE.
WHICH THE RULES COMMITTEE WAS
CARRYING FORTH SO WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THAT WAS A VOTE ON A
PROCEDURAL MATTER NOT IN THE
SUBSTANCE OF SB FIFTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER.
MEMBERS OF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BET BUSINESS. MADAM PRO TEMP
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH. A
BUSY DAY WITH A LOT OF ACTIVITY
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES- FURTHER PATIENTS
TODAY I THIS IS- THE WEEK OF
HOUSE OF ORIGIN DEADLINE FOR TO
YOUR BILLS SO I WANTED TO GIVE
MY COLLEAGUES- REMIND YOU THAT
WE WILL BE MEETING ON WEDNESDAY
NOT THURSDAY WEDNESDAY BEFORE
THURSDAY. WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH AT ELEVEN AM WE
HAVE OUR SEVEN- AS BEES THAT
NEED TO BE HEARD BEFORE THE END
OF THIS WEEKEND TO RESOLUTION
SO- BUT WE ALSO KNOW THESE ARE
TO YOUR BILLS AND THEREFORE
WEDNESDAY MAY BE A SOMEWHAT
LONG DAY SO I WANTED TO PREPARE
YOU FOR THAT. SO I WILL SEE YOU
ON WEDNESDAY THE TWENTY NINTH
AT ELEVEN AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. THANK
MADAM PRO TEM THE SENATE WILL
BE A JUROR AND WE WILL
RECONVENE WEDNESDAY AT ELEVEN
AM HAVE A GREAT DAY EVERYONE.